Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ja, das ist hier schon die 136.
Ausgabe, nachdem wir am letzten Wochenende schon die 135.
Ausgabe rausgehauen haben und ihr denkt euch, was, wie?
Ich dachte, UKW kommt alle nur ein paar Monate so. Ja, aber wir haben ja schon
angekündigt, wir wollten ja nochmal was einschieben. Das machen wir heute.
Mit anderen Worten, ich begrüße wieder einmal Pavel hier, hallo Pavel Genau,
denn wir wollten uns über die USA unterhalten, weil du warst in den USA und
warst auch relativ lange in den USA und warst auch nicht das erste Mal in den
USA und hast von daher einen deutlich besseren,
Eindruck als ich den jetzt vermitteln kann von meinen wenigen Besuchen,
die ich da vorgenommen habe.
Genau, und wir hatten ja euch gefragt, ob ihr Interesse daran habt,
da mal reinzuhören und da haben sich doch eine ganze Menge Leute gemeldet und
dann machen wir das halt auch einfach mal und das ist der Plan für die heutige Sendung.
Mit anderen Worten, wir machen hier so eine Mischung aus Reisebericht und allgemeinen Betrachtungen.
Ich denke nicht, dass wir jetzt den Anspruch haben, hier den ultimativen Einblick
in die USA, höre diesen Podcast und du weißt alles, was du schon immer über
die USA nie wissen wolltest.
Das ist nicht unser Ansatz, sondern das ist jetzt hier wahrscheinlich auch eine
sehr subjektive Betrachtung und wir schauen einfach mal, was sich daraus ableiten
lässt und was wir da selber für Schlüsse ziehen können.
Sicherlich auch ganz interessant, gerade jetzt in der aktuellen Situation,
wo wir so ein iratsch geführtes Land haben,
Was leider viel zu wichtig ist für die internationale Politik und internationale
Sicherheitspolitik und natürlich auch konkret jetzt hier für den Konflikt mit Ukraine,
um den es aber heute nicht gehen soll, sondern wir schauen uns einfach nur das
Land an und was Pavel alles so lustiges erlebt hat und dann gucken wir mal,
ob das spannend war oder nicht. Oder?
Ja, also die Hauptidee ist so ein bisschen so ein medialer Realitätsabgleich auf der einen Seite,
weil üblicherweise nimmt man die USA ja vor allem medial wahr in den Nachrichten
und dann stellt sich immer die Frage, okay, wie,
Allgemein ist denn das, was ich da gerade sehe oder wie spezifisch ausgewählt
ist das jetzt und lässt sich das überhaupt jetzt sagen, was weiß ich,
Proteste stattfinden gegen die Politik, welchen Umfang hat denn das tatsächlich so diese Proteste?
Sieht man was davon, wenn man jetzt tatsächlich da ist.
Das ist eine Sache und dann noch als Hintergrund.
Ich war nicht nur da, sondern bin 17.000 Kilometer durchs Land gefahren,
und habe irgendwie 27 von 50 Bundesstaaten besucht besucht und dort auch viel ja,
bin dort viel privat untergekommen eben bei Freunden und Verwandten von Freunden und so weiter, das heißt,
ja, ich habe dann quasi auch so ein bisschen gesehen, wie leben denn die Leute?
Wie viel verdienen sie? Was bezahlen sie für Strom und ja, wie ist der Zustand
der Häuser und ihrer Autos?
Und der Straßen und da kann ich glaube ich zwar auf der einen Seite subjektive
Sicht wiedergeben, auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt,
ich habe 27 Bundesstaaten auf jeden Fall durchquert, habe nicht in jedem übernachtet unbedingt,
aber in den meisten und kann dann
deswegen glaube ich auch ein bisschen verallgemeinern oder sagen okay,
hier ist es völlig anders als da.
Und beides, glaube ich, wollen wir mal versuchen heute.
Und ich hoffe, dass Tim dann auch mich ein bisschen ausquetschen wird.
Ja, also wir können ja mal 27 Bundesstaaten, hast du gesagt.
Ich habe also deine Reise so ein bisschen mitverfolgt.
Durch irgendwie Find My Pavel und wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe,
begann deine Reise in Washington State. Und dann in Oregon.
Warst du auch in Kalifornien? Ja. Dann Nevada.
Utah. Glaube ich auch.
Nee, Arizona.
Dann New Mexico rüber durch Texas, Oklahoma.
Jetzt muss ich raten, wahrscheinlich Arkansas.
Louisiana, Mississippi, Alabama.
Okay, und dann runter Florida und dann hoch die Küste, Georgia,
South Carolina, North Carolina, Virginia bis Washington DC.
Und ja, dann weiß ich nicht, Pennsylvania auch noch?
Ja, ja, ich meine, da liegen in der Ecke von Washington nur noch Maryland und
West Virginia und Pennsylvania.
Und da warst du auch überall?
Ja.
Ah, okay. Und dann Ohio rüber, Indiana, Michigan?
Ja, Michigan haben wir auch ausgelassen, aber Indiana und Illinois waren dann.
Achso, und dann hoch Minnesota oder so, ne?
Ja, Wisconsin, Minnesota.
Und dann auch durch Süd oder Nord Dakota?
Süd Dakota.
Süd Dakota. Ah ja, das finde ich am interessantesten. Und dann nehme ich an, Wyoming.
Bing, ja, Montana, Idaho.
Und dann muss man immer durch Idaho kurz durch, bevor man dann wieder in Washington State landet.
So, das zieht sich da geografisch hoch.
Also einiges gestreift.
Eine Runde, also von, ich sag mal, links oben in der USA.
Runter.
Also quasi von Seattle aus runter Richtung Kalifornien. dann rechts rüber Richtung
Osten bis Florida und dann wieder so nördlich.
Aber ich habe dann die ganze Washington-Ecke, also New England oder so ausgelassen.
Weil das war, ich sage, sieben Wochen und 17.000 Kilometer Fahrerei.
Und das wäre dann sonst wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber du warst wahrscheinlich auch in ein paar der Staaten, wo du jetzt nicht
warst. warst du auch schon mal vorher, oder?
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Genau, also wahrscheinlich, genau, also gerade New York und Delaware und...
Fragen wir doch mal andersrum, in welchem Staat hast du denn jetzt noch nie
deinen Fuß reingesetzt?
Ja, so...
Ich glaube, Alabama war ich dieses Mal.
Okay, ja, wie gesagt, es sind 10 bis 20 wird es sein.
Zum einen in der Mitte, also Utah zum Beispiel, war ein wichtiger Staat,
den man eigentlich auf der Liste gestanden hätte.
Und dann ja.
Also ich meine nicht, was du jetzt ausgelassen hast, sondern was du sozusagen
überhaupt noch nie betreten hast.
Wie gesagt, generell wahrscheinlich bleiben da, ich sag mal,
20 Staaten übrig oder so.
Einschließlich Alaska und Hawaii.
Ja, einschließlich Alaska und Hawaii war ich.
Ah, warst du auch. Also Experte. Das zählt im Internet als Experte.
Insofern bin ich sehr froh, dich als Experten heute.
In diesem Podcast begrüßen zu dürfen Also die meisten Amerikaner mit denen ich geredet habe,
meinten, waren verrückt irgendwie und sie selbst hätten noch nie so viele Bundesstaaten besucht.
Obwohl sie in Amerika leben Kein Zweifel Ja.
Ja Also insofern Ja,
aber natürlich sind es eben nur sehr punktuelle Eindrücke, aber eine ganze Menge
punktueller Eindrücke.
Und an Sehenswürdigkeiten, was auf dem Weg lag, haben wir natürlich mitgenommen.
Und ja, sie verdienen ihre Berühmtheit zurecht.
Also die USA hat einfach spektakulär viel Natur. Natur, was weiß ich,
angefangen, so von dem Regenwald in Washington State, diese gigantischen Bäume, auch viele Redwoods.
Dann natürlich kennt auch jeder irgendwann Death Valley und Grand Canyon.
Und dann haben wir natürlich Roswell, konnten uns natürlich nicht entgehen lassen.
Das ist natürlich sehen, was ist dahinter und in Roswell tatsächlich,
Ja, sehr, sehr viel Ufo-Kram, sehr viele Aliens, die dort, oder Alien-Statuen, die dort stehen.
Also die vermarkten das Ganze voll.
Also an den drei wichtigsten Ein- und Ausgangsstraßen hat auch irgendjemand
große Untertassen, fliegende Untertassen so an den Straßenrand montiert mit Aliens und so.
Alles private Initiative. und sogar der McDonalds dort ist halt als Raumschiff ausgebaut.
Hätte nichts anderes erwartet, um ehrlich zu sein. Das war auch so ein bisschen
meine Erfahrung, als ich in den
USA kam, dass so alles, was man so gesehen hat, war so ah ja, kenne ich.
Habe ich schon mal gesehen. Ist ja genauso, wie ich mir das dachte.
Also die kulturelle Bandbreite, die man so vermittelt bekommt durch Hollywood
und das ganze westlich geprägte.
Medienlandschaft, die ist so umfangreich, dass es wirklich schwierig ist,
schnell irgendwas zu entdecken, wo man sagt so, oh was ist das denn?
So was habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Und da tendiert man natürlich auch schnell dazu, das dann so generell abzutun
und zu sagen, das ist alles so, wie ich mir das schon immer vorgestellt habe,
jetzt kann ich auch gleich wieder zurückfliegen.
Nur mal eine kurze Anmerkung zu dem Umfang deines Trips. ich hab mal hier auf
dieser tollen Webseite thetruesize.com, kennst du die?
Da kannst du so Länder übereinander legen, um mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
wie groß ist das jetzt eigentlich wirklich? Ich hab mal die USA auf Europa draufgezogen.
Leider kann man das hier nur so hin und her schieben und nicht rotieren, aber ich hab jetzt mal so.
Grob deinen Startpunkt so an die Ostküste, Entschuldigung, an die Westküste
von Irland gelegt. Also da, wo du gestartet bist.
Dann bist du irgendwie runtergefahren dann ungefähr so bis Andorra, dann rüber so Rom,
dann weiter über Albanien, Bulgarien,
Istanbul, ganze Schwarze Meer und dann am Schluss bis so ein Jerewan gelandet.
Dann langsam die Küste hoch, schon ein bisschen tief nach Russland rein und
die Rückkehr dann über Belarus, Polen, Deutschland,
Holland, UK wieder zurück nach Irland, um sich mal vorzustellen,
was für eine Strecke du da abgeritten hast.
Ja, es ist groß. Also es ist größer, als man denkt.
Selbst wenn man sich vorstellt, es ist groß, es ist größer einfach.
Und es gibt halt Gegenden auch, da ist kein Mensch.
Da fährst du anderthalb Stunden lang Autobahn und da ist nichts.
Also außer der Autobahn.
Da gibt es keine Raststätte, keine Tankstelle, keine Häuser am Rand,
keine Hütten, keine Altestellen, einfach nichts.
Da ist einfach die Straße und in der Regel rechts oder links oder auf beiden
Seiten eine Stromleitung. so.
Und dann fährst du und dann fährst du auch eine Stunde und siehst vielleicht
ein oder zwei andere Autos, die dir entweder entgegenkommen oder vor dir fahren.
Also es gibt halt Gegenden, die sind einfach super, super leer.
Aber das war jetzt eher wahrscheinlich im Zentrum.
Ja, das war so Arizona die Ecke zum Beispiel.
Und auch Death Valley und so, so viele dieser Naturparks. sind halt groß.
Oder auch durch Texas oder dann durch Montana fährt man eben auch von morgens
bis abends, legt dann tausend Kilometer zurück und ist immer noch im selben Bundesstaat.
Naja. So wie Europa.
Also eigentlich kann man, klar ist es groß, aber es ist halt jetzt auch nicht
größer als Europa, wenn ich das jetzt hier mal so ein bisschen drehen könnte
und vielleicht mal so Russland,
weglassen würde. Es würde halt so wirklich von Spanien, dann Norwegen,
also ganz Skandinavien noch mit abdecken und von daher kann man es schon ganz gut vergleichen.
Nur man fährt halt ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit quer durch Europa.
Ja, ansonsten was vielleicht, um mal so zwei Dinger, zwei oder drei Sachen rauszugreifen,
die mich persönlich jetzt am meisten beeindruckt haben, so jetzt an der Natur.
Das war tatsächlich so Devil's Tower.
Das ist in Wyoming so ein Prinzip so ein erstarrter Basalt,
so 260 Meter hoch, 150 Meter im Durchmesser und ist eben bekannt auch natürlich
wieder aus diesem Spielberg-Film Unheimliche Begegnung der dritten Art.
Das ist dann, wo dort die Aliens ihre Basis oben drauf haben.
Aber das Ding einfach als reine Gesteinsformation.
Man kann da schön drum rum laufen. Dauert ungefähr eine Stunde,
einmal drum rum zu laufen, relativ nah.
Und man kann sogar das Ding beklettern.
Also das ist wieder interessant. Da sind die Amerikaner dann deutlich auch wieder
entspannter. So hier in Deutschland ist es ja mit Klettern und so,
in manchen Gegenden darf es halt keine Haken einschlagen und nichts.
Und da ist es so, wenn du Devil's Tower, wenn du da hochklettern willst,
musst du nur dich eintragen auf einer Liste,
damit sie gegebenenfalls dann Rettungsaktionen starten, wenn du irgendwie vermisst wirst oder so.
Also das fand ich auf jeden Fall einfach, das Ding sah wirklich aus wie aus einer anderen Welt.
Also sehr, natürlich bei den Ureinwohnern war das natürlich auch sehr dann heilig
eigentlich und kein Wunder.
Und Yellowstone.
Mit den ganzen Vulkanen und heißen Quellen ist auch echt krass.
Ich war froh, als ich da wieder wegfahre. Ich bin jetzt nicht so ein Freund
in der Nähe von Vulkanen oder auch heißen Quellen,
die dann teilweise schon mal auch explodieren können oder wo dann halt giftige Gase austreten.
Aber wie gesagt, es sieht eben auch alles sehr spektakulär aus.
Und du kannst da überall rumwandern. Also da sind Tausende von heißen Quellen und Geysieren,
die dampfen und blubbern und komische Kruste haben und auch super gefährliche Bakterien.
Und der Boden ist instabil und du darfst halt nicht von den Wegen runter,
sonst kannst du halt einbrechen und in irgendwie so ein Loch mit kochendem Wasser reinfallen oder so.
Also es ist alles nicht voller Faint of Art und ja, also Natur.
Und ich bin dann allerdings auf dem Rundgang, dummerweise, hier war ich dann
mit kurzen Hosen und Sandalen unterwegs und bin dann in so einen Schnee- und
Eissturm geraten und durfte dann irgendwie sehr leicht bekleidet, ja.
Dann durch einen Schnee- und Eissturm wandern.
Wo kam der denn auf einmal her?
Ja, Berge. Berge wechselt das Wetter, kann halt da sehr schnell wechseln.
Und es waren halt dunkle Wolken.
Aber man ist ja dann so, was soll's, wird schon gut gehen.
Ist nicht, ja. Also das waren auf jeden Fall die spektakulärsten.
Und vielleicht noch Mount Rushmore. Also wo diese Präsidentenfiguren eingehauen
sind, das selbst, das Denkmal, das habe ich mir mehr oder weniger gespart.
Das ist ein riesiger Parkplatz, da kann man besser von außen sehen.
Aber sie haben dort eine ungefähr 100 Kilometer lange Straße in das Gebirge
gehauen, die eigentlich nur dazu dient,
sich die Natur anzugucken und haben dann die Tunnel, die sie dort gemacht haben.
Alle auf Mount Rushmore ausgerichtet.
Das heißt, da sind dann mehrere Tunnel.
Wenn du da durchguckst, siehst du halt am Ende des Tunnels, wie in so einem
Fernrohr, siehst du halt Mount Rushmore.
Und sie haben, weil sie irgendwie Kurven oder Brückenkurven so geil fanden,
haben sie dort dann auch so mehrere Spiralbrücken, die halt über sich selbst drüber führen.
Einfach nur so for the lulz, also weil sie das nett fanden. Und diese Strecke
ist also auch, also lohnt sich, wenn man zufällig in der Gegend sein sollte,
sich irgendwie einen Tag zu nehmen.
Motorrad ist auch super Motorrad und mit auch extrem spektakulären Pelsen,
also mit den spektakulärsten Felsformationen, die ich gesehen habe,
aber auch bewaldet und so.
Also das, wie gesagt, Mount Rushmodder, die Gegend ist halt ziemlich geil.
Ja, ich denke, dass vielleicht...
Also man muss ja auch sagen, jetzt in die USA zu reisen als Tourist und dann
zwei Wochen, fünf Wochen irgendwie rumzuhängen und Geld auszulieben,
ich sag mal, ist gerade nicht so populär.
Ich schaue mir gerade viele Videos von irgendwelchen entrüsteten Kanadiern an,
die also wirklich mit Argos Augen
beobachten, wie doch die gesamte Tourismusindustrie in den USA leidet.
Das hat viel mit Trump zu tun.
Es hat nicht nur mit Trump zu tun, interessanterweise. Es kommen auch noch ein
paar andere Sachen dazu.
Also Las Vegas zum Beispiel hat wohl gerade absurde Rückgänge,
die nicht jetzt nur damit zu tun haben, dass viele Länder die USA boykottieren,
sondern auch ein paar Fehler, die sie so seit Covid gemacht haben,
wodurch das alles viel zu teuer geworden ist.
Aber ja, ich weiß, du konntest sozusagen nicht Nein sagen.
Aus Gründen, aber hast du denn gemerkt, dass irgendwie weniger Tourismus da
war in irgendeiner Form oder dass es sich nur um Amerikaner handelt oder so?
Schwierig zu vergleichen wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich meine das Einzige, wo ich das vielleicht beurteilen oder vergleichen
könnte, wäre Las Vegas, wo wir auch durchgekommen sind.
Ich war Anfang der 90er schon mal in Las Vegas.
Und erstens hat sich Las Vegas so krass verändert, dass entgegen der Pläne ich
dann gesagt habe, lass uns lieber weiterfahren und außerhalb bleiben,
weil ich fand es ganz furchtbar.
Und es war aber tatsächlich, ja, also in Las Vegas,
Wie gesagt.
War nicht super voll, also schien mir nicht super voll zu sein,
was so den Fußverkehr angeht, aber ich habe da jetzt keinen Vergleich,
aber ich fand es sehr unangenehm.
Also es waren irgendwie, dass jemand,
der kein Problem hat, in Berlin unterwegs zu sein, da waren einfach sehr viele
betrunkene Leute unterwegs dort im öffentlichen Raum und alles ist so halb maul
und halb überdacht und halb klimatisiert.
Und es ist halt, ja, es ist halt zwar fußläufig, aber du läufst nicht entlang
irgendwelcher Straßen, sondern
durch irgendwelche Unterführungen und irgendwelche Komplexe durch und so.
Also ich fand es sehr, sehr schrecklich. Und die Leute waren alle sehr aggressiv,
im Gegensatz zum Rest der USA, wo die meisten Leute sich relativ entspannt waren, mit Ausnahmen.
Ja, also direkt, ich meine, sagen wir mal so, Es war kein Problem,
irgendwie günstige Airbnbs auch zu finden.
Also man hatte nicht das Gefühl, dass das Land irgendwie ausgebucht ist,
aber es war auch nicht Saison unbedingt.
Deshalb schwer zu sagen.
Ich dachte nur, vielleicht ist es ja auch mal irgendwo ein Thema gewesen in der Form.
Ja, also es ist tatsächlich nicht wirklich, ich habe es natürlich medial verfolgt,
aber jetzt vor Ort ist es nicht so aufgekommen.
Also mit den Gastgebern oder mit den Freunden war es jetzt nicht so das Thema.
Interessanterweise.
Ja, noch irgendwas zum Thema Natur und Geografie, was du noch erwähnen willst,
wo du warst oder gerne gewesen wärst oder nie wieder hin willst?
Also vielleicht so ein paar bemerkenswerte Dinge, die mich überrascht haben
noch. nicht so erwartet hatte.
Die Mitte der USA quasi ist halt eine Hochebene, also speziell Idaho,
Montana, Wyoming und Dakotas.
Und diese Hochebene ist ungefähr 1000 Meter hoch und flach.
Und riesig groß. Also 1000 mal 1000 Kilometer oder so, flach, hoch, hoch.
Aber keine Gebirge, bis man dann irgendwie an die Gebirgsketten rankommt.
Und dann geht es nochmal 1.000 bis 2.000 Meter nach oben.
Und da wohnen also viele Leute dann ganz nah auf 1.500 oder 2.000 Metern.
Und es kommt hier nicht besonders hoch vor, weil wie gesagt,
Null ist schon bei 1.000 Metern.
Ja. Und das führt dann aber dazu,
dass tatsächlich die Luft ungefähr eine Dichte hat, die mit Verkehrsflugzeugen
vergleichbar ist mit der Cabin Altitude, die so zwischen 2.000 und 3.000 Metern liegt.
Was halt dazu führt, dass eben das Essen anders schmeckt und du anders kochen musst in dieser Höhe.
Also die ganzen Kochzeiten, die du so gehörst, gewohnt bist und Temperaturen
sind eben alle verschieden und nennt sich halt High Altitude Cooking.
Das war mir neu und eine ganze Menge Amerikaner, gut, wiederum so viele leben
dann dort nicht, aber müssen halt High Altitude Cooking betreiben.
Also bei 2000 Metern Höhe liegt der Siedepunkt von Wasser bei 93 Grad.
Ja, macht einen Unterschied. Für Tee zum Beispiel, ich meine, Und.
Ja, es ist schon eine interessante Information. Die habe ich jetzt auch in Deutschland
noch nicht so überprüft.
Man merkt es auch. Aber falls man, also High Altitude Cooking googeln und dann
so regeln, wie man dann die Garzeiten anpassen, das ist irgendwie so 10% je 1000 Meter.
Egal. Ja, also das fand ich sehr bemerkenswert.
Und dann ist es dort aber in vielen Gegenden, also du hast sehr kalte Winter und sehr heiße Sommer,
also die Extreme auch im Wetter sind halt deutlich größer und es wird dann plötzlich
im Frühjahr, also im Mai als wir da waren,
wird es dann auf einmal richtig heiß in manchen Gegenden plötzlich.
Selbst im Norden, wo dann gerade der Schnee weg ist, hast du auf einmal drei,
vier Wochen später 25 bis 30 Grad Tagestemperaturen.
Und dann ist es eben jetzt auch in Montana speziell, wo wir ein paar Tage im
Gebirge verbracht haben,
war die Luft extrem trocken, was dann wiederum dazu führt, dass wenn du draußen
bist bei 5 Grad, du gar nicht das Gefühl hast, dass es jetzt irgendwie kalt
ist, als wenn jetzt kein Wind weht.
Also es ist halt dann Windstille und extrem trockene Luft und du hast eine komplett
andere Temperaturwahrnehmung.
Also ganz seltsam. Du sitzt halt draußen bei 5 Grad und brauchst nicht mal eine
dicke Jacke. Sehr seltsam.
Ja.
Und dann auch extreme Unterschiede durch die Gebiete im Niederschlag.
Da in Washington, wo alles abgeregnet, sind halt die Regenwälder mit gigantischen
Bäumen, die eben deswegen dort wachsen, weil es so viel regnet.
Das ist jetzt nicht tropischer Regenwald, das ist halt mehr so Regenwald, Nadelregenwald.
Im Wald, aber eben mit diesen Redwoods, die dann zuhauf noch dort sind,
obwohl die Amerikaner, ich weiß nicht, 95% abgeholzt haben schon,
aber die verbleibenden 5%,
die da sind, sind auch schon sehr umwerfend.
Also wo du dann Bäume mit Durchmesser von 2 Metern hast du am laufenden Band
und dann so hast du auch manchmal 3, 4, 5 Meter Durchmesser,
Bäume, die dann auch einfach ziemlich hoch sind. Und ja, das ist schon sehr...
Also das, was wir unter Mammutbaum kennen.
Genau, und dann ja, was mich auch überrascht hatte, dass die Westküste,
die Pazifikküste, die ist sehr unwirtlich.
Direkt an der Küste lebt auch kaum jemand, weil es ist windig,
die Geografie sehr, sehr bergig zerklüftet und auch die Küste selbst mit vielen
Felsen so gefährlich für Schiffe und Du.
Meinst jetzt in Washington oder?
Ja, in Washington und Oregon, die Küste ist für eine sehr nette Straße lang die auch,
wirklich sehenswert ist aber ja auch sehr, sehr unwirtlich.
Und ich habe mal eine Frage zu Oregon, weil das ist ja so ein Staat, von dem man nie was hört.
Außer, dass es da mal den Oregon Trail gab.
Ich glaube, das ist nur das Einzige. Und ich muss jetzt sogar nachschlagen,
weil ich irgendwie noch nicht mal weiß, was da die Hauptstadt ist.
Und jetzt sehe ich, die heißt Salem und ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jemals wusste.
Und das ist offensichtlich auch keine besonders große Stadt mit, was hat die?
175.000 Kerneinwohner, Metropolregion, 433.000.
Also was ist falsch an Oregon, dass sich da nichts Großes ansiedelt?
Weil das nur aus Bergen besteht?
Ja, also die meiste Kram ist so 20, 30, 40 Kilometer Inland,
weil die Küste ist so, hat wenig große Häfen,
sondern die Häfen sind quasi eher
Inlandshäfen, die in der Nähe oder an Flussmündungen sich befinden dort.
Und es gibt dann eben auch kaum Ost-West-Verbindungen, also zwischen Küste und
jetzt dem Hinterland, sag ich mal.
Und ich meine, das andere Ding generell, die USA ist halt groß und ist halt,
einfach dünn besiedelt, weil in vielen Gegenden ist halt vor allem Klima und Geografie,
eignen sich nicht gut für Straßenbau kannst da nichts anbauen oder schwer Häuser
zu bauen oder ja in dem Fall, wie gesagt, Häfen Ah.
Portland ist in Oregon und Portland.
Ja Portland ist so die eine ziemlich geile Stadt Ich würde sagen,
es ist auch eher eine linksliberale Stadt und dort gibt es ein Buchkaufhaus,
so ein komplettes Kaufhaus,
Was, ja, vor allem Antiquariat jetzt, aber gigantisch.
Also das größte Buchkaufhaus, was ich je gesehen habe, Antiquariat.
Wer also interessiert ist, englische Bücher zu browsen und zufällig mal in Portland,
das ist sehr beeindruckend.
Powell's oder was? Powell's City of Books.
Ja und dort, wie gesagt,
gibt es eben auch teilweise Gegenden, wo die fußläufig sind,
also wo man dann einfach auch zu Fuß von einer Kneipe zur anderen gehen kann
oder von einem Restaurant zum anderen.
Na gut, aber wir waren ja gar nicht so sehr bei den Städten,
sondern bei der Natur und der Geografie. Haben wir da noch was zu erwähnen?
Ja, ich meine, dann wenn wir jetzt gerade, wie gesagt, Washington und da ist
es natürlich Mount Rainier und Mount St.
Helens, der 1980 explodiert ist, das kann man von weitem sehen,
wie ein Stück fehlt von dem Berg.
Ganz gut sichtbar und es ist auch nette Gegend und was dort viele Leute machen
eben als Freizeitaktivitäten, es gibt halt dort viele Trails, wie sich das nennt.
Es sind halt einfach ja im Prinzip Waldwege und die Leute fahren dann dahin
und gehen dann dort wandern.
Und je nachdem führen die Trails dann irgendwie entweder ins Gebirge rauf oder so.
Und dann gibt es dort eben auch sehr viele Gebirgsflüsse.
Und diese Gebirgsflüsse einfach runter zu paddeln oder zu raften,
das ist auch eine beliebte Freizeitbeschäftigung.
Ich habe es nicht gemacht, aber wir haben ja,
Wir haben Leute dabei beobachtet an verschiedenen Flüssen, die runtergetrieben sind.
Dieser Mount St. Helens, der halt, wann war das?
80.
Genau, 80, genau.
Da kann ich mich sogar noch ein bisschen dran erinnern, dass das irgendwie mal so ein Weltthema war.
Weil er halt dann, wie schon erwähnt hast,
einen signifikanten Teil seiner Spitze eingebüßt hat und dabei ja auch ganze
Ökosysteme ausradiert hat und seitdem ist die ganze Region natürlich bei Biologen
und anderen Naturforschern und Geologen natürlich auch super interessant zu sehen,
wie dann eben so komplett zerstörte Seen sich dann über die Jahrzehnte wiederhergestellt haben.
Obwohl sie halt so mit giftigen Vulkanschlacken einmal alles ausradiert haben.
Aber daran kann man halt wieder schön sehen, wie schnell teilweise die Natur
in der Lage ist, sich wieder neu zu erfinden.
Aber da weiß ich gar nicht so viel drüber.
Was man dort auch überall mitkriegt, sind halt so ein bisschen die Geschichte der USA,
natürlich dann verschiedene Trails sind dann nach den Entdeckern benannt,
was weiß ich, die Lewis und Clark Expedition.
Im Prinzip ganz viel lang gefahren, wo die entlang gezogen sind und dann die ganzen Schlachten,
wo dann Ureinwohner abgeschlachtet wurden oder irgendwie gelegentlich auch mal gewonnen haben.
Da stehen halt dann überall Schilder, so Historic Point, hier war das,
also entlang der Straße, da kann man sich dann irgendwie durchlesen,
was denn dann gerade hier passiert ist.
Also die finden sich auch überall zuhauf, den USA.
Es ist ja schon mal schön, wenn
sie darauf hinweisen, dass die ganzen Urheilwohner abgeschlachtet sind.
Und was eben auch auffällt, dass es eben überall so auch Indianer-Ureinwohner-Reservate gibt,
die dann einen speziellen rechtlichen Status haben und dann bestimmte Gesetze anders sind.
Und manche verkaufen dann besonders günstigen Tabak und Zigaretten.
Das ist sehr beliebt, weil auch die Zigarettenpreise schwanken in den USA zwischen 5 und 12 Dollar.
Okay.
Und Tabak, also Drehtabak gibt es kaum.
Und da zahlt man dann also bis zu 35 Dollar für ein Päckchen Drehtabak,
also für ein Päckchen American Spirit, allerdings 50 Gramm, 32 Dollar.
That's the spirit.
That's the spirit, ja. Und dann noch nicht mal Feinschnitt, sondern Grobschnitt.
Also im Prinzip, wie wenn du die Zigaretten ausleerst.
Du Armer, naja, dann fahren wir nach Neuseeland, da hast du noch ganz andere
Sorgen, was Tabak betrifft, da gibt es nämlich keinen mehr.
Ja, okay.
Ja, aber ansonsten vielleicht noch, das jetzt Washington abzuschließen,
die Einreise war extrem entspannt, ich hatte mich natürlich auf alles vorbereitet
und war auch ein bisschen beunruhigt.
Aber ja,
ich bin mehr oder weniger durchgewunken worden also es hat keine 60 Sekunden
gedauert und mir wurde nicht eine einzige Frage gestellt,
du warst enttäuscht ich war dann völlig verwirrt,
und ja also Also insofern kann ich, wenn man einreisen will,
kann ich Seattle empfehlen als Ziel,
dort schien es insgesamt recht entspannt zuzugehen.
Und die Immigration und Customs, also die Eisleute waren sehr nett und freundlich
und zuvorkommend und haben rumgescherzt und alles irgendwie sehr unerwartet
entspannt, muss ich sagen.
Wir geben keine Garantien ab.
Genau, wir geben keine Garantien ab. Das kann sich natürlich alles geändert haben.
Und das ist nur ein Ding, aber ich konnte dort nichts beobachten.
Und auch die braunen Leute wurden auch ganz normal abgefertigt und hatten keine
Probleme dort, je weit ich sehen konnte.
Also nichts Auffälliges, deutlich entspannter als nach 9-11, so war mein Eindruck.
Das Theater war wahrscheinlich sofort vorbei, nachdem du durchgewunken warst.
Erst raus. Jetzt wieder Business as usual.
Okay.
Gut. So viel vielleicht zur Geografie, denke ich.
Zur Anreise.
Ja, das Erste, was einem ja dann wahrscheinlich auffällt, wenn man so viel durch
die Gegend fährt, ist der Verkehr.
Dafür ist ja die USA auch irgendwo bekannt, dass sie im Wesentlichen aus Verkehr besteht.
Autoverkehr.
Aus Autoverkehr besteht vor allem, genau. Und ja, ich kann mir vorstellen,
das dürfte dann auch der dominante Eindruck gewesen sein auf deiner Strecke.
Oh ja, gerade natürlich, wenn man aus Deutschland kommt mit einer speziellen Fahrkultur,
so ist natürlich die amerikanische Fahrkultur eine doch deutlich andere.
Es gibt auch Gemeinsamkeiten, aber es fängt erstmal damit an, ich war überrascht,
dass die Leute alle sehr schnell unterwegs waren, also schneller als ich dachte.
Ich kannte das von früher, naja, da hast du halt die 55 oder 65 Meilen und an
manchen Stellen etwas schneller,
also im Prinzip zwischen 100 und 110 einfach ist die Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung
auf Autobahnen dort und dementsprechend geht alles etwas entspannter zu, aber mitnichten.
Also die Hälfte der Leute fährt 10 Meilen über der Geschwindigkeitslimit,
also 15-16 kmh.
Und ja, aber was ein bisschen spooky daran ist, ist, dass es nicht nur die PKW machen,
sondern ja auch LKW und natürlich dann auch die Trucks,
also jetzt die SUVs mit gigantischen Anhängern, die dann teilweise 15 oder 20
Meter lange Anhänger hinter sich herziehen.
Entweder Wohnmobile oder ich weiß es nicht, Strohtransportanhänger,
Segelflugzeuge, was weiß ich, was die da drin haben.
Ja, wenn man keine Züge hat.
Der Schwertransport, also ich habe einen Schwertransport überholt auf der Strecke,
der so Windturbinen geladen hatte,
die so 100 Meter lang sind.
Also kennt man ja hier auch von der Autobahn so, ja, nur, dass dieser Schwertransport
sich mit 120 kmh ungefähr über die Autobahn bewegte und echt schwer zu überholen war.
Und generell, also LKW, es gibt dort keine einheitliche Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung
wie hier in Europa, wo du sagen kannst,
also im Prinzip siehst du selten einen LKW hier, der über 90 fährt,
auch wegen Fahrtenschreibern und so.
Und in den USA fahren die Lkw einfach schneller.
Also zwischen 100 und 120 sind die Lkw dort regelmäßig unterwegs und teilweise sogar legal,
weil es eben in manchen Staaten keine speziellen Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkungen
auf manchen Strecken für Lkw gibt. Das heißt.
Ja, die sind sehr zügig unterwegs. Natürlich auch insgesamt,
ich meine, es ist deutlich gefährlicher.
Also USA liegt, was die so Unfalltote angeht, wie Rumänien ungefähr auf dem Niveau.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ist denn das in Rumänien?
Ja, tendenziell hoch. Also es ist im Vergleich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist zwei
bis dreimal höher als die Unfallwahrscheinlichkeit als in Deutschland.
Also es ist deutlich gefährlicher,
auf einer amerikanischen Autobahn mit Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung unterwegs
zu sein, als auf einer deutschen Autobahn ohne. Ja.
Was auch Gründe hat.
Und mit dem LKW ist es auch so, ich wunderte mich, die einzigen,
die Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung einhalten, waren Walmart-Trucks,
weil die remote überwacht werden.
Und ansonsten aber fast alle überholen. Also mit 70 bis 75 Meilen sind die typischerweise
unterwegs bis 80 Meilen pro Stunde.
Das sind typische LKW-Geschwindigkeiten.
Und das führt erstens auch dazu, also ein Ding, was auch sichtbar ist,
ist, dass so sehr viele geplatzte LKW-Reifen am Straßenrand sind.
Es gibt Gegenden, da hat man das Gefühl, da häuten sich irgendwie diese LKW,
so wie Schlangen, werfen das Gummi ab.
Da hast du dann teilweise mehrere Kilometer, wo über mehrere Kilometer hinweg
Gummi-Reste von Autoreifen liegen.
Also wo du nicht rechts ranfahren kannst, ohne auf einem Stück kaputten LKW-Reifen
auf der Standspur zu fahren. zu fahren.
Ja, und da hatte ich mir ja, haben die denn keine Fahrtenschreiber dort,
die überwacht werden wie in Europa?
Und tatsächlich gibt es die erst seit 2017 sind elektronische Fahrtenschreiber
in den USA bundesweit vorgeschrieben, aber es gibt natürlich und wir sehen natürlich
wieder viele Ausnahmen.
Die gelten nicht für Lkw vor Baujahr 2000, nicht für Überführungsfahrten und
nicht für Lkw, die nur in einem Umkreis von 150 Meilen operieren.
Die brauchen alle keinen Fahrtenschreiber.
Und wahrscheinlich.
Sind viele auch manipuliert. Auf jeden Fall,
ist es teilweise echt unangenehm, mit diesem wirklich sehr schnellen LKW unterwegs zu sein.
Und wenn du Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung einhältst, wirst du ständig von LKW überholt.
Das ist das eigentliche Problem. Das heißt, du bist eigentlich auch gezwungen,
die Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung zu überschreiten, wenn du nicht ständig von LKW
überholt werden willst.
Ja,
das Beste sind eigentlich immer Abstandsautomatik. Das ist so die einzige Erfindung
in diesem intelligenten Fahren, die wirklich sinnvoll ist und die man eigentlich
immer haben will, aber die man seltener hat.
Und unser Auto hatte glücklicherweise so etwas und das war sehr, sehr praktisch.
Und auch, ich weiß nicht, es herrscht auch irgendwie nicht so,
mein gut, das hat man hier auch, aber so Gefahrenbewusstsein,
zum Beispiel bei Baustellen, wird dort in der Regel nicht verlangsamt.
Also auch, da sind dann Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen, aber für die interessiert
sich dann keiner, weshalb auch die Strafen verdoppelt sind in der Regel. Das ist das Schilder.
Strafen verdoppelt oder irgendwie, wer so und so viel zu schnell in der Baustelle
fährt, Gefängnisstrafe und so. Scheint aber niemanden zu interessieren.
Aber es gibt offenbar Staaten, da wird mehr eingehalten.
Das ist mir auch aufgefallen, dass es Staaten gab, Da fahren die Leute,
halten sich mehr an die Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen, was vermutlich daran lag,
dass eben auch mehr Enforcement stattfindet.
Und ja, ein Ding ist, es gibt fast gar keine Radarfallen in den USA.
Und wenn, dann werden die mit fünf Schildern vorher angekündigt.
Aber ich habe vielleicht drei Radarfallen gesehen oder Blitzer,
sagen wir so, also fest installierte Blitzer.
Was es gibt stattdessen, sind in der Regel
auf dem Mittelstreifen geparkte Polizeifahrzeuge, die dann quer stehen.
Deswegen denkt man erstmal, ja eigentlich Radar, kennt man hier,
ist irgendwie immer vorne oder hinten am Fahrzeug hier bei uns.
Aber dort lasern sie zur Seite raus, das heißt, sie stehen dann dort quer,
gucken sich den Verkehr an und lasern alle, die vorbeikommen.
Und wenn jemand schnell genug fährt, dass sich das lohnt,
hinterherzufahren, dann fahren sie raus, schalten die Sirene an und blinken dich raus.
Und was natürlich bedeutet, dass wenn du nur jetzt 10 Meilen oder 8 oder 9 Meilen
zu schnell fährst, lohnt sich das nicht für die.
Rauszufahren, sondern du musst dann schon mit zu den schnellsten gehören oder
relativ, also die Toleranz ist
dadurch relativ hoch, weil der Aufwand für die, dir ein Ticket zu geben,
relativ hoch ist und ich bin nur einmal rausgewunken worden in Alabama und das
war ein eher lustiges Erlebnis,
weil der Beamte, der dann auch schweren Südstaaten Akzent sprach,
so schwer zu verstehen,
hatte dann vor allem Probleme mit meinem laxfarbenen Führerschein.
Du hast noch so einen alten sozusagen.
So einen Papierführerschein. Genau, so einen alten EU-Führerschein.
Und das Einzige, was dort in Englisch draufsteht, ist ganz klein Driving License.
So in sechs verschiedenen Sprachen. Und ansonsten ist natürlich alles auf Deutsch,
aber es gibt jede Menge Stempel.
Also es sieht viel offizießer aus. Aber er drehte das Ding.
Sechsmal rum und faltete das auf und suchte und kam nicht damit klar und meinte,
das sei kein gültiger Führerschein.
Aber er war sich dann am Ende halt auch nicht so sicher, weil er sagte,
ich war hier seit 25 Jahren mit diesem Führerschein.
Durchs Land, ja. Und dann, naja, war das Problem, dass er halt irgendwie so
jetzt einem Ausländer ein Ticket zu geben, war jetzt auch kompliziert und er
war sich dann auch nicht sicher.
Und jedenfalls wegen zu kompliziert hat er mich dann auch einfach so fahren
lassen, hat mir nie gesagt, wie viel zu schnell ich war. Aber ich war dann so
ungefähr 15 Meilen zu schnell wahrscheinlich.
Ja, und er beklagte sich dann aber bei mir dann darüber, dass er meinte dann,
if you want to do speed, you need a valid driver's license.
Und sagte das auch genauso, if you want to do speed, was natürlich auch eine andere Bedeutung hat.
Aber er war halt mehr empört, vor allem darüber, dass ich keinen ordentlichen
Führerschein hatte und mir deswegen keinen Strafzettel schreiben konnte.
Und hat uns dann einfach weiterfahren lassen. Das ist eine gute Fahrt.
Internationaler Führerschein heißt da wahrscheinlich die Lösung.
Dann kriegst du auch ein ordentliches Ticket.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Das hast du dann wahrscheinlich auch noch nie gesehen.
Ja, und genau, und dann auch noch so, ja, wo kommen Sie denn her?
Ja, Berlin und Budapest.
Out of state.
Kann man wohl sagen.
Ja, also offensichtlich ist es allein schon eine Komplikation,
ein Ticket an jemanden aus einem anderen Bundesstaat auszustellen und irgendwie
von einem anderen Kontinent wollte einfach nichts mit zu tun haben.
Ja, also ja,
Und ich meine, ein Problem ist mir halt noch aufgefallen, mit dieser Polizei
kennt ja jeder aus dem Film,
während in Deutschland, wenn man rausgewunken wird, überholt die Polizei und
hält die Kelle raus oder macht das Bitte-Folgen-Schild an.
Während in den USA setzen sie sich hinter dich und machen halt die Sirene an.
Problem ist nur, sie machen halt auch die Sirene an, wenn sie irgendwie schnell
vorankommen wollen und wollen, dass du irgendwie Platz machst.
Und das führt natürlich zu Konfusionen bei Leuten, wenn dann ein Polizeiwagen
einfach durchkommen will,
die gehen dann erstmal auf die Bremse und machen dann keinen Platz,
weil sie denken, der will jetzt hinter mir bleiben und mich anhalten.
So man teilweise experimentiert man jetzt mit anderen Sirenentönen in den USA
für ich will durch und bitte fahr jetzt rechts ran.
Aber das ist halt so ein Fuck up, den sie wahrscheinlich nie beseitigt kriegen.
Deshalb die Polizei einfach Schwierigkeiten hat durchzukommen,
weil auch Rettungsgassen ist so ein Ding, das ist da auch nicht so super verbreitet.
Und so, ja, also das ist mir eben auch noch aufgefallen, was jetzt die Polizei angeht.
Und ja, Abstand halten ist auch, es fahren alle extrem dicht auf,
weil sie glauben, sie haben supergute Bremsen.
Weshalb bei Auffahrunfällen meistens zwei oder drei oder vier Autos verwickelt sind.
Und das Straßennetz. Also ...
Ich habe in meinem Leben knapp zwei Millionen Kilometer mit dem Auto zurückgelegt.
Autofahren ist mehr oder weniger im Kleinhirn drin.
Aber was in den USA einfach sehr unangenehm ist, sind die Auffahrten und Abfahrten, die teilweise...
Teilweise, also du weißt teilweise nicht,
auf was für einer Art von Straße befinde ich mich, weil der Übergang von normaler
Landstraße zu Vollhighway ist so ein bisschen fließend.
Und auch auf einem Vollhighway, die Auf- und Abfahrten sind anders designt.
Die Auffahrten sind sehr kurz und verschmelzen dann mit der rechten Fahrspur.
Das heißt, du fährst halt auf und einer muss dann Platz machen.
Deswegen fahren die Leute auch so ungern auf der rechten Fahrspur,
weil die halt mit anderen Fahrspuren sogar verschmilzt.
Und die Abfahrten statt Kurven, die gehen die so schräg in einem Winkel oft ab.
Das heißt, du sollst halt nicht auf der Autobahn dann bremsen,
sondern erst dann auf der Abfahrt, wenn du aber runter bist.
Während du hier halt eine Verzögerungsspur
hast, ist die Verzögerungsspur nicht mehr auf der Autobahn.
Aber das ist noch ganz okay. Teilweise gibt es dann halt überhaupt gar keine
Verzögerungs- oder Bremsspur.
Es gibt dann auch Abfahrten, die knicken dann einfach orthogonal ab auf manchen
Highways oder da kommt dann von rechts oder von links kreuzen dann Fahrzeuge einfach ab.
Kleine Straße, die allerdings aussieht wie eine Autobahn mit einer riesigen
Leitplanke in der Mitte und mit einem Mittelstreifen von 15 Metern und zwei- oder dreispurig,
aber es ist halt in dem Sinne keine Autobahn unbedingt und das heißt,
und dann die Beschilderung ist teilweise auch wirklich irreführend,
Das ist das andere Problem.
Dass du oft mehrfach in irgendwelchen Abfahrten gelandet bist,
die gar nicht die Abfahrt waren,
sondern irgendwie einfach eine provisorische Vorabfahrt, wo zwar dann das Schild stand,
aber da musste man halt irgendwie weiterdenken und einfach ignorieren,
dass diese Abfahrt, das Schild gehört halt zu einer anderen Abfahrt, zu der übernächsten.
Da musste man teilweise wirklich aufpassen,
speziell bei Nacht, weil auch mit Reflektoren und allem erinnert das dann teilweise
mehr an Entwicklungsländer in manchen Stellen.
Ich fand das schon teilweise anstrengender dort, gerade wenn dann viel Verkehr
ist oder sonst, deutlich aufmerksamer fahren als hier.
Da sind wir natürlich auch, glaube ich, ein bisschen, ich bin nicht verwöhnt
sagen, aber Deutschland ist halt auch alles irgendwie übermarkiert. Also vor allem,
Straßenschilder, Wahnsinn also alles muss irgendwie ein eigenes Straßenschild
bekommen bis du einfach literally den Wald vor lauter Schildern nicht mehr siehst und,
ja da ist das ja auch so ich meine wenn du da so Straßen hast die dann erstmal
so wo du erstmal einen Tag geradeaus fährst,
ohne dass irgendwas kommt ich meine ist ja klar, dass du dir um solche Details
irgendwie keine Gedanken machst
Aber du malst wahrscheinlich jetzt auch innerhalb von Städten und so, ne?
Ja, ja. Und wie gesagt, es gibt eine gewisse Standardisierung,
aber dann gibt es eben auch, aber man kann sich halt absolut nicht drauf verlassen.
Und dann, was auch unterschiedlich ist, so bei Autobahnkreuzen,
hier ist man ja in der Regel das Kleeblatt gewohnt.
So wie bei einem Autobahnkreuz, wo man relativ genau weiß, wie das funktioniert.
Es ist alles sehr einfach so in den USA.
Aber sind Kleeblätter nicht so
verbreitet, weil eben Kleeblätter sind auch gleichzeitig am wahrsamsten,
was Platz angeht, sondern stattdessen sind Autobahnkreuze ein riesiger Verhau an Straßen,
Brücken, Unterführungen, also teilweise auf fünf verschiedenen Ebenen geht das
über und untereinander her.
Und da muss man halt wirklich genau aufpassen, Abfahrten sind öfter auch mal
links statt rechts und so.
Also diese Verhaue im Grund ist, weil man effizienter sein möchte und vermeiden
möchte, dass wie beim Kleeblatt halt die Leute zu oft Spuren wechseln müssen.
Dann ist halt quasi jede Richtung mit jeder über eine direkte Brücke oder Abfahrt verbunden.
Und das verbraucht dann allerdings das Mehrfache an Platz natürlich,
weswegen es in Europa nicht so verbreitet ist, während man in den USA einfach, da ist Platz.
Also das merkt man eben überall, dass die Leute das Gefühl haben,
da ist Platz, jedenfalls in weiten Teilen der USA.
Ja, plus Parkplätze, außer jetzt in älteren Städten oder Stadtzentren hast du
überall leere Parkplätze, natürlich, wenn du einkaufen fährst oder so.
Also ich meine, die USA hat auch über eine Milliarde Parkplätze für 300 Millionen Autos oder so.
Das heißt, wenn man Einwohner, das heißt meistens Parkplätze.
Und was mir aber auch dann aufgefallen ist, ich habe tatsächlich einmal das
Auto genommen, nur um zu einem Restaurant auf der anderen Straßenseite zu fahren.
Weil das war eine fünfspurige Straße ohne Fußgängerübergangsmöglichkeit nachts.
Sag ich mir, nee.
Ja, und bin halt, weiß nicht, 150 Meter mit dem Auto gefahren,
nur um nicht diesen fünfspurigen Highway zu Fuß überqueren zu müssen.
Absolut nachvollziehbar und so machen das ja auch alle. Wir kommen jetzt auch schon so langsam,
touchieren wir ja halt auch so ein Kernproblem der USA und nirgendwo macht sich
das glaube ich so breit wie im Verkehrsbereich,
nämlich einerseits so die marode Infrastruktur,
das hast du ja auch schon angesprochen,
aber eben auch diese Durchformatierung des gesamten Landes und vor allem auch
der Städte durch Straßen und alles ist aufs Auto orientiert.
Das erzeugt ja eine ganze Menge Probleme und mal von solchen offensichtlichen Problemen,
wie dass man nirgendwo zu Fuß hingehen kann und du aus dieser Spirale auch gar
nicht mehr rauskommst, dass du eigentlich für alles das Auto nehmen musst.
Weil es gibt keine Alternativen.
Also weder gibt es.
Fußwege, noch Fahrradwege, wo man sagen könnte, auf einer lokalen Ebene könnte
ich ja auch mal das Auto stehen lassen oder da mal kurz hingehen,
weil es ist ja nur 150 Meter.
Aber das wird ja dann schon vollkommen unmöglich gemacht durch das Straßendesign
und dann eben diese riesigen Straßen, die eigentlich bei uns eher Autobahnen wären.
Sodass du das dann eben nicht machst und dass du natürlich auch noch das ganze
Layout der Städte selbst, die,
einerseits völlig krass immer zwischen so gewerblichen Gebieten und Wohngebieten
unterscheiden, in denen noch nicht mal ein Supermarkt stehen darf,
sodass du auch nichts in der Nähe hast.
Also von Walkable City will ich gar nicht sprechen, aber überhaupt so mal die
Infrastruktur, die die Leute einfach regelmäßig brauchen, mal dahin zu verlegen, wo die Leute sind,
Und das kommt vielen Städten dort überhaupt nicht in den Sinn,
weil sie sowas wie ein Supermarkt schon als Bedrohung des Wohnens empfinden,
weil natürlich diese Supermärkte dann auch immer diese riesigen Mengen an Parkplätzen
mit sich bringen, weil ja alle mit dem Auto unterwegs sind.
Also die Idee, so einen lokalen Tante-Emma-Laden in einem Wohngebiet zu haben,
das geht teilweise rechtlich gar nicht und irgendwie kommt den Gemeinden auch
gar nicht der Gedanke, weil das ist ja überall so.
Also tatsächlich ist es wohl so, es gibt Gegenden, speziell in Washington D.C.
Zum Beispiel, gibt es auch eine Menge, Viertel, die fußläufig sind.
Der Punkt ist, alles, was vor
1920 an Stadtzentren oder an Häusern oder an Stadtvierteln gebaut wurde,
ist mehr oder weniger mit Europa vergleichbar, von der Dichte und von der Struktur.
Aber ab 1920 gibt es das nicht mehr, weil wie du richtig gesagt hast,
wegen Satzungen und so weiter, wegen Auto.
Und das Problem ist, man kann solche Viertel heute auch nur ganz schwer wieder bauen,
sodass die wenigen, ich sag mal knappen übrig gebliebenen fußläufigen Gegenden sind begrenzt.
Die sind nicht vermehrbar.
Das ist halt auch, weshalb es halt dann super teuer ist, jetzt in solchen Gegenden
zu wohnen. Und in Washington aber ja, gab es...
Ganz normal, wie man es hier auch kennt, mit Anwohnerparken und einem Haufen
zweistöckiger Reihenhäuser und Fahrradwegen,
Radfahrern, Joggern, die unterwegs waren und mit Supermärkten,
die in Fußnähe waren tatsächlich.
Aber das hast du nur in so City-Gebieten?
Wie gesagt, uns in Cities tatsächlich nur was aus den 1902-1920 übrig geblieben.
Und die in der Folge nicht nochmal platt gemacht wurden. Es gab ja auch sehr
viele Städte, da ist dann auch nochmal das alte Stadtzentrum abgerissen worden,
weil das muss ja jetzt ja alles fürs Auto gemacht werden.
Also das war ja im Prinzip auch die Lobby Nummer schlechthin,
also wo einfach die Automobilindustrie,
ganz stark Einfluss genommen hat auf die Städte und auf die Regierung,
damit entsprechende Gesetze auch erlassen werden,
dass so Straftatsbestände wie Jaywalking eingeführt werden, also wenn du sozusagen
als Fußgänger über eine Straße gehst und es ist nicht grün, dass das dann sozusagen bestraft wird.
Alles wurde auf das Auto ausgerichtet, aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch für
die USA eine totale Falle.
Also nicht nur, weil das halt sinnloser Energieverbrauch ist,
die Vereinzelung der Menschen nochmal extrem vorantreibt, weil da halt einfach
überhaupt gar keine Communities entstehen können, beziehungsweise Communities
nicht da entstehen können, wo man zusammen lebt,
sondern Communities sich eigentlich nur noch an Veranstaltungsorten, an Kirchen.
Sportveranstaltungen, wo genug Parkplätze sind, abspielen können oder in Shoppingmalls,
also alles auch in kommerziellen Umfeldern nur noch stattfinden kann,
aber es kaum nicht kommerzielle Umfelder gibt, wo du eine Community hast,
vielleicht noch Schule oder sowas, aber das war es dann halt auch schon.
Und das zweite Problem ist.
Die Maintenance von diesen Infrastrukturen, die sie da gebaut haben, die wird richtig teuer.
Und das ist halt jetzt schon ein Hauptgrund für die Verschuldung und die mangelnde
Investitionen auch in andere Dinge, weil einfach für nichts anderes mehr Kohle
da ist, außer Straßen permanent auszubessern, wenn es denn überhaupt noch stattfindet.
Also entweder findet es nicht statt, die Straßen sind in einem ziemlich schlechten
Zustand, ich schätze mal, das dürftest du auch gesehen haben,
oder da wo sie nicht in einem schlechten Zustand sind,
geben sie einfach höllisch viel Geld aus, nur um diese sinnlose Zahl an Straßen aufrecht zu erhalten,
die man halt braucht, weil man sich eine Infrastruktur, ein Layout zugelegt
hat, was eben Straßen für Autos braucht.
Und Autos machen halt diese Straßen schnell kaputt und dadurch verdienst du halt auch nix.
Also der Landverbrauch ist ja so enorm, wenn du da auch nur so einen normalen
McDonalds hast mit McDrive, so, ne, dann ist da erstmal so ein riesiger Parkplatz drumherum.
Und schon der nächste Laden, wenn er sich mal nicht zufällig die Fläche teilt
jetzt mit einem anderen Laden, aber normalerweise hast du ja dann,
wieder die nächste Ausfahrt und dann wieder ganz viele Parkplätze um den nächsten
Burger King drum und der nächste Klamottenladen oder der nächste Shopping Mall
ist auch wieder von Kilometer,
Hunderten von Metern von Parkplatzfläche getrennt und für die Gemeinden ist
das eigentlich total kontraproduktiv,
weil die kaum Umsätze machen pro Quadratmeter.
Also die Flächen, die sie haben, werfen einfach nichts ab, während wenn du jetzt
so ein normales europäisches Hauptstadtdesign hättest, also Also Fußgängerzone
muss auch nicht mal eine Fußgängerzone sein.
Einfach so diese Dichte, die wir so, sagen wir mal, aus unseren Hauptstädten
oder überhaupt aus unseren Städten kennen, wo du so ein Zentrum hast oder auch
außerhalb des Zentrums viele Läden hast, da machen ja die Gemeinden ihr Geld.
Die wirtschaftliche Aktivität führt ja dazu, dass die Gemeinden überhaupt das Geld haben.
Stattdessen besteht eigentlich alles nur noch aus Parkplätzen,
die einfach nur teuer sind.
Vor allem die Maintenance der Straßen ist halt teuer. Aber sie verdienen damit
halt einfach gar kein Geld.
Also es macht einfach hinten und vorne überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Und es hat auch noch ein paar andere Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft.
Da kommen wir sicherlich später noch zu.
Ja, also dort wird halt an vielen Stellen eher auf, ich sag mal,
Quantität statt auf Qualität gesetzt.
Das ist so ein bisschen, ja, überprovisorisch und zeigt sich auch bei der Straßenqualität.
Die ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Also es gibt Stellen, wo offensichtlich.
Sie in der Lage sind, Autobahnen zu bauen, die glatt sind, einen guten Fahrbahnbelag
haben und insgesamt, wo es sich gut drauf fährt.
Aber du hast dann auch entweder Stellen, wo Straßen, die komplett kaputt sind,
also kaputter, als ich das in Berlin je gesehen habe.
Das ist so eher, weiß ich nicht, 90er Jahre DDR, frühe 90er Jahre ehemaliger
Osten, irgendwie ein bisschen in der Provinz.
So erinnerte mich das stark dran.
Aber was ich dann am krassesten fand, waren dann Teile des Highways gerade frisch
asphaltiert worden, so mit einem großen Schild natürlich.
Das ist jetzt durch die Biden-Initiative,
jetzt hier Biden-Infrastruktur-Initiative, beziehungsweise sie wurde dann dort
als Bipartisan Infrastructure Initiative, hat jetzt diese folgenden 50 Kilometer Highway neu gemacht.
Und dann fährst du dort auf einem frischen Belag und der ist einfach uneben, es rubbelt.
Wo du dir denkst, ich sag mal, die bauen doch so viele Straßen und mittlerweile
machen das ja eigentlich Maschinen, die in der Lage sind,
einfach perfekt glatte Straßen zu bauen, selbst wenn du einfach nur drüber asphaltierst,
du fräst halt den Belag weg und ja.
Nur ganz offensichtlich kommen diese Maschinen nicht überall zum Einsatz.
Ich habe dann auch gesehen, wie die dann diese Straßen machen und teilweise
machen die das ganz normal wie vor 100 Jahren auch mit so einer Maschine,
die dann den Asphalt verteilt und mit so einer Dampfwalze, die dann hin und her fährt.
Und ja, ich meine, das muss jetzt nicht verkehrt sein, aber so siehst du,
während hier siehst du auf den Autobahnen, wenn die das machen,
haben die ja diese gigantischen Maschinen und die fahren dann rüber und die
werden dann in der Regel, ja,
funktioniert das auch.
Und wie gesagt, in den USA gibt es das auch, aber da wären halt auch knallhart
Autobahnen, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich hat in der Gegend keine Firma irgendwie so etwas und es wäre
zu teuer, das Equipment ranzuschaffen.
Und dann wird dann halt mit dem gearbeitet, was dann halt so eine Firma eben
an Equipment vielleicht auf dem Gebrauchtmarkt geschossen hat und so den Eindruck erweckt.
Also es war auch schon immer mein Eindruck von den USA, dass sie eine extreme
Diskrepanz haben in der Modernisierung ihrer Technik.
Übrigens einen ähnlichen Eindruck habe ich auch von Großbritannien,
dass du zwar schon Hightech hast,
klar, ich meine, es sind ja auch in vielen Bereichen in der Forschung und Elektronik
und so weiter ganz weit vorne, Aber was so das Maschinelle betrifft.
Gibt es einfach da nicht so Sachen, die bei uns so gang und gäbe sind.
Das bezieht sich auf Maschinen, das bezieht sich auf Werkzeuge,
auf Befestigungssysteme. Sagen wir mal sowas Einfaches wie, wie verbindet man
zwei Kabel miteinander?
Wenn du da in so ein Home Depot reinlatscht und sagst, hier Elektrik,
wie verbinde ich denn sowas?
Der Standard ist ja so diese komische Cable Nut oder wie das heißt.
Schraubst dann irgendwie so eine komische wie so ein Zahnpasta Deckel auf die
Kabel drauf, die dann damit irgendwie zusammengezwirbelt werden und das soll
dann irgendwie die Verbindung der Kabel sein,
wo du halt hier irgendwie so Vago-Klemmen irgendwie schon als totalen Standard
hast und wenn du jetzt hier in so einen Elektrikladen reingehst oder Klempner
oder sowas das hat halt einfach alles eine andere,
Qualität und klar, das findet man sicherlich hier und da, auch in USA,
aber auch so bei Maschinen und im Alltagskram wirkt es teilweise dann doch deutlich
rückständiger, auch was so Müllentsorgung und so weiter betrifft.
Ja, vielleicht,
Und dann noch zum Schluss, was jetzt den Verkehr angeht oder den Autoverkehr.
Die USA ist ja bekannt für ihre niedrigen Benzinpreise, aber das ist ja,
es ist auch eher relativ.
Also da ich in sehr, sehr vielen Bundesstaaten getankt habe,
weiß ich jetzt auch ganz genau, wie der Spritpreis war im Mai und Juni.
Nämlich zwischen 2,25 Dollar pro Gallone in New Mexico und 4,75 Dollar in Kalifornien.
Also zwischen 60 Cent und 1,26 Dollar pro Liter wären das.
Deutlich günstiger als bei uns, aber zumindest in Kalifornien.
So kann man jetzt nicht sagen, dass das jetzt extrem viel billiger ist.
Die 60 Cent sind extrem, aber die 1,26 gehen ganz schön ins Geld,
zumal auch in den USA der Durchschnittsverbrauch,
höher liegt von 1,26.
Euro 1,26 Euro 1,26 Euro pro Liter hast du gesagt, umgerechnet.
Okay, also das ist so knapp 1,10 Euro ungefähr derzeit.
Das ist ja jetzt erstmal günstig, aber das wird dann halt einfach durch den
höheren Verbrauch wahrscheinlich aufgefressen.
Also läuft es nicht so viel.
Teilweise so. Und dann, wie gesagt, sind halt eben jeder Bundesstaat erhebt
halt ganz unterschiedliche Steuern auf Benzin.
Und Diesel ist auch teurer in der Regel als Benzin.
So ein paar 10, 20, 30 Cent teurer und ja,
also ganz so billig ist es jetzt nicht,
aber ich sag mal, vielleicht die Hälfte, jetzt zahlt man für einen Sprit,
wenn man das jetzt auch noch nach Kaufkraft bereinigt, jetzt nochmal anpasst.
Aber ja, vor allem teuer ist es vor allem interessanterweise an den Küsten,
Man würde ja denken, da kommt das Öl an.
Aber ja, und Texas war auch nicht am billigsten, interessanterweise.
So würde man auch denken.
Aber war auch eher bei den billigen Staaten.
Während Kalifornien, Oregon und Washington haben halt eher höhere Spritpreise.
Und Florida war auch nicht so billig.
Ja, also...
Insofern, ja, alles etwas verschwenderischer.
Wenig überraschend, finde ich. Weil für Verschwendung sind die USA ja irgendwie bekannt.
Also wir auch, das gleich voranzustellen.
Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, alles was bei uns scheiße läuft,
das hat sich so in den USA immer mindestens so doppelt so extrem abgebildet.
Kannst du das bestätigen? Ja, also ich meine, vielleicht schaffen wir es auch
irgendwann zu positiven Dingen zu kommen.
Achso, das hat man doch schon. Das sieht da ganz hübsch aus und so, die Bärme sind nett.
Ja, ja, ja, aber so ansonsten ja generell einfach viel Plastik.
So kann man es ist was, was auch auffällt, so dass Glasflaschen einfach die Ausnahme sind.
Und sie mittlerweile sogar dazu übergehen, Spirituosen der Mittelklasse,
also selbst in Plastikflaschen, also Wodka zum Beispiel,
in Plastikflaschen oder Whisky in Plastikflaschen abzufüllen.
Und ja,
dann ist es natürlich so, Also auch überhaupt zehn Staaten haben Pfand auf Getränkebehälter
so, meistens fünf Cent, aber irgendwie,
ich weiß nicht, habe ich gar keine Pfandrückgabestellen oder so gesehen.
Ich glaube, die Leute zahlen das einfach und dann stellen das am Straßenrand
ab oder so und überlassen das dann anderen.
Und ja, generell auch Plastikmöbel sind deutlich mehr verbreitet.
Also das ist dann auch die Betten aus Plastik und natürlich Stühle aus Plastik.
Betten aus Plastik.
Ja, und Schränke aus Plastik.
Schränke aus Plastik.
Mhm, das ist also, wie gesagt, ist verbreitet.
Ist deutlich verbreiteter als hier.
Dann hast du natürlich auch, ich meine, bei uns ist es ja schon schlimm mit
doppelt verpackt, Aber da habe ich teilweise wirklich viele Sachen dreifach verpackt.
Also ab Werk.
Eine Verkaufsverpackung, eventuell noch mit Zellophan,
ein Karton mit Zellophan, dann machst du die auf und da ist dann noch eine Unterverpackung
drin und dann ist noch mal jedes Teil noch mal einzeln eingepackt.
Also das hat man auch häufig. aber am lustigsten fand ich.
Die haben ja nicht diese Plastikkappen auf den Flaschen, wie jetzt in der EU
vorgeschrieben sind, die halt an der Flasche dranbleiben müssen.
Wo wir uns erstmal, glaube ich, viele aufgeregt haben, was ist das denn für ein Mist?
Warum ist denn das da dran?
Amerika hat das nicht. Ich habe mich jetzt mittlerweile, ich festgestellt,
so sehr daran gewöhnt, dass die Kappen in der Regel dranbleiben,
dass ich das total nervig und rückständig fand,
dass die Plastikkappen einfach abfallen.
Also gerade, wenn du im Auto unterwegs bist oder im Auto mal einen Schluck aus
der Flasche nimmst, ist es total praktisch, dass du nicht irgendwie eine Hand
für den Deckel oder den dann irgendwo ablegen oder wie auch immer,
sondern ja, und da dachte ich, was ist das denn, hier fallen ja die Deckel von den Flaschen ab.
So sehr kann man sich an neue Dinge gewöhnen. viele Leute jetzt sagen, ah, furchtbar Das.
Ist wirklich ein interessanter Aspekt ich meine, das haben ja auch einige Leute
darüber aufgeregt, so im Sinne von, ja, okay um sowas kümmern wir uns jetzt,
aber hier die großen Probleme, die bleiben anteckend,
absolut berechtigte Kritik und es daran festzumachen, okay aber tatsächlich
ist der Praktikabilitäts Aspekt dabei nicht zu verachten, also stimmt schon,
ich finde es, jetzt wo du es sagst, geht es mir genauso im Film.
Mir war das erst aufgefallen, als es plötzlich nicht mehr da war. Und,
Insofern ja und dementsprechend natürlich aber auch so dieses viel Plastik so
färbt halt auch auf Häuser.
Also es ist eine totale, wie sagt man, Scourge, also es verfolgt einen und es
ist ja auch nicht nur jetzt in den USA so.
Also auch wenn du jetzt innerhalb von Europa die Länder wechselst,
da hast du ja dann auch eine andere Tendenz. und ehrlich gesagt,
es hängt auch so ein bisschen davon ab, wo man kauft.
Also gehst du schon mal in einen anderen Supermarkt, so Aldi,
Lidl und so, da bin ich dann auch immer wieder abgeturnt davon,
wie viel dort in Plastikflaschen angeboten wird und auch wie das so mit den,
Verpackungen so ist, weil das ja oft auch,
ein Mittel der Verkaufsstrategie und so weiter ist.
Okay, bei uns ist viel Kartonage am Start, wo man vielleicht jetzt in den USA
Plastik erwarten würde, aber ich hatte jetzt zum Beispiel in meiner Zeit in Spanien,
auch den Eindruck, dass dort mit Plastik anders nicht so gut umgeht,
also es mehr ist, also insbesondere jetzt bei Getränken, aber nicht nur dort.
Ja, nee, generell ist, ja, gebe ich dir recht, ist in vielen europäischen Ländern auch, ja,
ist man plastikaffiner, sage ich mal, oder macht sich nicht so viele Gedanken darüber.
Ja, also aus dem Stichwort ein bisschen Wegwerfmentalität, glaube ich,
wie das früher hieß oder heute vielleicht, man das auch noch bezeichnen kann.
Das findet sich eben auch sehr viel in Häusern wieder, beziehungsweise dieser
Quantität statt Qualität und gucken,
lieber billig und öfter was Neues als irgendwie teuer und dann warten und instand halten.
So, das ist so eine, ich meine, philosophiefähig ist das in den meisten Ländern
der Welt so, nur in Deutschland anders oder in einer Handvoll Länder wie Deutschland
anders, dass man einfach auf,
größeren Wert auf Wartung und Instandhaltung setzt.
Ist schon stark ausgeprägt bei uns.
Könnte auch noch ausgeprägter sein. Also ich finde, an der Stelle können wir
uns gerne weiter radikalisieren oder auch zumindest mal wieder dahin zurückkommen, wo wir schon mal waren.
Weil wir sind ja nicht frei von Wegwerfmentalität.
Und ich würde sagen, das zeigt sich halt auch ganz deutlich,
auch wenn das natürlich auch ein globales Problem ist, bei so Geräten.
Also du kaufst halt irgendwelche Geräte und die Scheiße ist einfach nicht mehr
ordentlich zusammengeschraubt, geht einfach viel zu schnell kaputt.
Und dieses wer billig kauft, kauft dreimal Ding, das gilt leider viel zu oft.
Und das ist, was mich immer völlig fertig macht, ist, wenn es einem nicht gelingt,
bei irgendeinem Produkt, also dass es noch nicht mal die Option ordentlich gibt.
Also dass du wirklich nur noch Trash kaufen kannst. und ich merke das halt auch
immer wieder, wenn ich so meine Komfortzone Metropolregion Berlin verlasse,
ja, was weiß ich jetzt, weil ich mal irgendwie so.
In Polen für ein paar Tage und da mal dann im Supermarkt und dann hast du so
eine Liste mit so Sachen, die du kaufen willst und,
diese Produkte existieren einfach gar nicht oder existieren zumindest nicht
in der Qualität, in der du es
jetzt irgendwie erwarten würdest und du hast halt auch gar kein Angebot.
Aber unabhängig vom Angebot ist halt auch immer die Frage, wie sehr orientierst
du dich an Langlebigkeit und inwiefern orientierst du dich an Langlebigkeit?
Good enough for the moment. Und ich glaube, so good enough for the moment ist
definitiv in den USA halt auch ein Thema.
Ja, es hat, glaube ich, auch was damit zu tun, dass dort viele Städte schnell geboomt wird.
Und dann aber auch, wenn der Boom vorbei ist, dass dann sehr schnell man zulässt,
dass dort Geisterstädte entstehen oder die Leute ziehen dann einfach weg.
Um das auch vielfach zu beobachten, immer wieder einfach auch Häuserruinen.
So Häuser, teils freistehende Häuser, teils in manchen Städten,
Auch in der Nähe vom Death Valley gibt es eine ganze Reihe von kleineren Städten,
die mal größere Erze oder andere Minen abgebaut haben,
die dann natürlich zurückgefahren sind.
Und wo du einfach siehst, die da im Verfall sind, im Rückgang sitzt,
wo die Hälfte der Häuser in der Stadt einfach verfallen sind, wo aber noch was ist.
Und dann hast du halt regelrecht Geisterstädte, Hunderte, Tausende,
wo die irgendwann mal gebaut und wieder aufgegeben geworden sind.
Und dann guckt so ein Haus, also ein neues Haus ohne Grundstück jetzt,
wenn du dir so ein Haus kaufen willst, geht bei 150.000 Dollar los ungefähr,
so aus der Fabrik jetzt produziert und angekarrt auf dem LKW und dann vor Ort zusammengebaut.
Also geht bei 150.000 los und jetzt für ein normales Haus, wenn man jetzt nicht
irgendwie so ein gigantisches Mac Mansion hat oder so, geht das schon bis 300.000 Dollar hoch.
Also ein Haus kostet ungefähr so viel wie ein Camping, wie ein großer Campingbus.
Aber es fühlt sich auch oft so an, wenn du in diesen Häusern bist.
Die Türen fühlen sich oft super leicht an.
Die Riegel und so hat man das Gefühl, das ist fast Wohnwagentechnologie.
Das sind so kleine, dünne Blechlaschen und so.
Und ja, also ich hatte die ganze Zeit das Gefühl, eigentlich in Ferienhäusern zu übernachten,
weil das alles, die haben halt so, ja, Holz und leicht und alles fühlt sich
nicht so richtig steinig an.
Ich meine, klar ist jetzt Gewohnheit, aber es gibt auch Steinhäuser,
ich habe da eine Ausschau gehalten.
Das ist natürlich dann auch wieder abhängig von der Gegend und der Geografie.
Aber grundsätzlich hat man da herausgefunden, jetzt vor 60, 70 Jahren,
wie man Häuser wirklich, wirklich billig bauen kann.
Und da gibt es so eine Bauweise und an der orientieren sich alle.
Und das ist ja schnell und billig.
Und ja.
In normalen Häusern, die Badewannen, sind die, wie man das vielleicht aus dem
Hotel oder Motel kennt, in der Regel sehr niedrig, in der Regel so kurz,
dass man sich nicht ausstrecken kann.
Duschen hast du selten einen Duschschlauch dabei, das ist dann also alles schon Luxus,
sondern da hast du halt dann ja ein Hahn, da kommt das Wasser für die Badewanne
raus, das Badewasser und dann eine fest montierte Dusche oben,
da kommt dann das Duschwasser raus. aber nichts mit Handbrause oder so.
Also das ist dann schon die Ausnahme.
Interessanterweise Handbrausen scheinen auch nicht so sehr verbreitet zu sein.
Ja, da ist so ein Auslass an einer Wand und dann kommt das Wasser raus.
Ja.
Das ist einfach kulturell festgenagelt. Ich meine, genauso wie du in Großbritannien
jetzt langsam erst, also jetzt ist das so langsam Standard, dass das Konzept
einer Mischbatterie sich durchsetzt.
Also dass so heißes Wasser und kaltes Wasser sozusagen getrennt ist.
Und ja, das, man füttelt sich nicht im Kopf.
Ja, ich hatte einmal in Großbritannien, war ich in einem Haus,
da war im Badezimmer Teppichboden, so Flukati-mäßig in Rot, kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Da fand ich interessant, wer verlegt eigentlich, ist das jetzt üblich,
dass man Teppich hat im Bad, also Teppichboden im Bad in Großbritannien?
Generell gibt es viel Teppich in Großbritannien.
Also so Teppich in Wohnungen ist eigentlich sehr verbreitet,
auch in Hotels und so weiter. Hast du das oft?
Man mag Teppich. Und es mag durchaus sein, dass es sich auch bis ins Bad erstreckt
auf meiner letzten Reise, wo ich in ein paar Hotels war.
Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht drauf geachtet, aber ich meine,
keinen Teppich gesehen zu haben im Badezimmer.
Ja, ja.
Also, bleiben wir bei den USA.
Jedenfalls, ja, in den USA dann die auch dann diese Türen, Türklinken und Schlösser,
fühlt sich alles nicht so super an und dann, wenn die,
Denn dann die Hauseingangstürme, gut, Deutschland hat ja die Tradition von richtig
teure, schwere Hauseingangstür.
Also sie muss, ja, und thermisch isoliert und so und wasserdicht und weiß der Geier was, nicht alles.
Also in den USA macht man das einfacher, wenn die normale Tür,
weil die halt nicht dicht genug ist, wenn es regnet, setzt man halt einfach
noch eine zweite Sturmtür davor, die dann das Wasser von der Tür abhält,
damit die Tür nicht nass wird und das Wasser reinläuft.
Ich habe dann auch gefragt, dann heißt das, habt ihr eine Tür vor eurer Tür,
die dann die Tür davor schützt?
Ja, scheint auch recht normal zu sein.
Und ja, ist gut. Achso, und dann?
Das war ich, dass wir an den Türen bleiben. Türen und was ja auch krass ist, sind ja auch Fenster.
Ich finde es immer so lustig, wenn man sich so Videos anschaut,
es gibt ja so eine ganze Menge,
Amerikaner, die jetzt in Deutschland leben. Weißt du?
Oder auch umgekehrt, aber vor allem ist ja immer so dieses Interessante,
was schockiert Amerikaner, die nach Deutschland, oder fasziniert und schockiert
Leute, die nach Deutschland kommen und jetzt hier irgendwie wohnen.
Oder auch nur für kurze Zeit da sind.
Und Nummer eins, wirklich auf allen Kanälen, sind unsere Kippfenster.
Das ist für die Space Technology.
Also solide,
gut isolierte Fenster, die man aufmachen kann und die man mit einem Dreh kippen
kann, das ist vollkommen unbekannt in den USA.
Und stattdessen hast du dann teilweise immer noch so diese albernen Hochschiebfenster.
Das ist ja auch in Großbritannien auch so eine Plage.
Also man merkt auch einfach, es gibt da nicht dieses Handwerk.
Da muss man ja auch mal sehen, Das hat ja meistens auch alles so eine historische
Komponente und wir haben nun hier in Europa und speziell eben in Deutschland den Vorteil,
dass wir eben so über hunderte von Jahren hat sich da so eine Handwerkskunst
ausgebildet und für jeden Scheiß gibt es hier halt einfach auch irgendwo mal
einen Spezialisten und mittlerweile einen mittelständischen Betrieb,
der sich eben um Türklinken kümmert.
Und da gibt es aber nicht nur einen, sondern es gibt halt 150 Türklinkenhersteller,
die irgendwie in einem brachialen Qualitätswettbewerb miteinander stehen.
Und es gibt natürlich auch Installateure, die mit dieser ganzen Technologie vertraut sind.
Ich schätze mal, in den USA, selbst wenn du als Hausbauer,
Besitzer, Käufer mit der deutschesten aller deutschen Mentalitäten da reingehst
und sagst, wir bauen jetzt aber hier mal ein richtiges Haus,
so mit Steinen und Isolierung und ordentlichen Fenstern und ordentlichen Türen,
du hättest schlicht Probleme,
a, überhaupt das Material zu bekommen.
Also baut ja keiner, hat ja keiner, ist nicht da, existiert einfach nicht,
das Werkzeug zu bekommen, was du brauchst, um das irgendwie auch alles ordentlich
zusammenzubringen, die Maschinen,
Verbundmaterialien, alles mögliche, Pipapo, Nägel, Werkzeuge.
Es ist halt einfach gar nicht machbar. Also es ist überhaupt nichts anderes da.
Und von daher wird halt so ein bisschen dieses Gute-Nav gebaut.
Und das andere Ding, glaube ich, was hier noch mit reinspielt,
ist, dass so ein Haus bei uns hat glaube ich ein Haus auch eine andere Bedeutung.
Also ein Haus ist hier wirklich so die Investition deines Lebens,
das baust du so und dann bleibst du da bis ans Ende deiner Tage.
Und klar ziehen auch mal Leute aus und verkaufen ihr Haus und bauen sich nochmal eins.
Aber die Regel ist, dass so ein Haus, so Home is my castle. Und in den USA habe
ich eher so den Eindruck,
Das ist mehr so eine Art Parkplatz, so eine Parkplatzsituation in ihrem Leben
und dementsprechend wird es sehr viel temporärer betrachtet.
Ja, weil eben auch die Mobilität ist dort deutlich höher und die Leute mieten auch weniger,
sondern da wird dann ein Haus gekauft und dann zieht man weg und dann verkauft man das und kauft Neues.
Es ist nicht unüblich, dass man so als Amerikaner der Mittelklasse drei,
vier, fünf Häuser im Laufe seines Lebens besitzt.
Das ist jetzt nichts Ungewöhnliches oder so.
Genau und deswegen muss es auch nicht so lange halten. Nach zehn Jahren ist
es dann irgendwie durch und dann wird es im Zweifelsfall halt auch eher abgerissen.
Und gerade bei den Wohnlagen, von denen du gesprochen hast oder diesen verlassenen
Städten oder Stadtteilen, ist ja dann auch oft so, dass du dann eben sehr viele
von diesen Häusern, die du überhaupt nicht mehr bewohnt hast,
hast, weil keine Nachfrage,
gibt da keine Jobs und Städte wie Chicago hatten da also auch das Problem, dass hier einfach,
Entschuldigung, nicht Chicago, Detroit, genau, Detroit.
Also die halt so extrem da unter dieser Deindustrialisierung gelitten haben,
dass sie also ganze Stadtteile hatten,
die halt einfach zu 80 Prozent dann nur noch aus leeren Häusern bestanden und
die Strategie, da überhaupt wieder Leben reinzubringen ist,
schlicht einfach diese ganzen Häuser einfach komplett wegzunehmen und abzureißen
und dann mehr oder weniger vom Scratch zu starten.
Weil wenn du dann erstmal ein verfallenes Haus hast, dann wirkt sich das eben
auf die ganze Neighborhood auch entsprechend aus. Naja.
Sidetrack. Also ja, ist so eine Sache mit der Infrastruktur und wenn ich das
auch richtig sehe, sind die Häuser jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer an so eine
öffentliche Kanalisation angeschlossen, oder?
Ja, ich hatte den Eindruck, dass ziemlich jedes zweite Haus,
wo ich übernachtet habe,
eine Sickergrube hatte und eben nicht an die Kanalisation angeschlossen war.
Und habe dann geguckt und in der Tat ist es so,
dass in Gesamt-USA 20 Prozent der Haushalte nicht an die Kanalisation angeschlossen sind.
In vielen Staaten aber über 50 Prozent nicht angeschlossen sind an die Kanalisation,
sondern da kommt dann alle paar Wochen eben ein Lkw vorbei und entleert die
Sickergrube und bringt das dann irgendwo zur Kläranlage.
Und die Vergleichszahl in Deutschland ist 3 Prozent. Also in Deutschland sind
drei Prozent der Einwohner nicht an die Kanalisation angeschlossen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt bei den Dimensionen, die man dort hat und den ländlichen
Regionen, die wir schon beschrieben haben, ist jetzt auch nicht sonderlich überraschend,
dass es da andere Zahlen hat.
Ja, aber das macht natürlich auch ohne Ende Probleme.
Also Sickergruben waren mehrfach ein Thema, dass dann eines der Bäder gerade
nicht benutzt werden konnte, weil es irgendwie Probleme gibt.
Weil dann irgendwie zwei Sickergruben
und die sind nicht ordentlich synchronisiert und keine Ahnung.
Also ja, und generell, also viele kleinere Hauskatastrophen oder mehrere habe
ich dann so mitbekommen.
Andere Katastrophe war, dass sich dort jemand einen neuen Wäschetrockner oder
Waschmaschine hat liefern lassen und dann,
Ja, ich meine, hier schraubt man das einfach an,
aber da gibt es halt dann wohl verschiedene Systeme und jedenfalls war dann
wohl auch irgendwie der Anschluss undicht und deswegen hatte die Hausbesitzerin
dann einen Handwerker sich geholt, der ihr die anschließen sollte.
Was meinst du mit verschiedenen Systeme von Trocknern?
Verschiedene Querschnitte, Anschlüsse und Wasser und Abwasser.
Jedenfalls konnte sie keinen Klempner finden.
Gut, das Problem hat man hier ja teilweise auch. Aber in den USA natürlich findige
Geschäftsleute haben sich auch die Klempner-Not zum Geschäft gemacht.
Und jetzt gibt es dort das Konzept der Verkaufshandwerker oder Vertriebshandwerker.
Das heißt, die schicken dir dann einen Klempner und der Klempner versucht dir
dann aber weitere Produkte anzudrehen.
Also du musst dann quasi ein Verkaufsgespräch über dich ergehen lassen,
um quasi wie diese Butterfahrten...
Damit dir überhaupt geholfen wird, musst du halt eine Verkaufsveranstaltung
über dich ergehen lassen.
Nur war der Handwerker wohl jetzt auch nicht besonders qualifiziert und hat
dann das ganze Ding so angeschlossen,
dass der Anschluss tropfte.
Einfach der Wasseranschluss tropfte dann und weil das quasi irgendwie drei Wochen
nicht da war, ist halt in drei Wochen hat sich das gesamte Haus mit Wasser vollgesogen,
Und komplett verzogen, sodass dann erst mal quasi Handwerker kommen mussten,
um das wieder auszunivellieren mit Hydraulikstempeln und allem.
Erst mal versuchen mussten, das Haus wieder gerade zu machen,
mussten sämtliche Türrahmen und Türen erneuern.
Und ja, also ein Riesenakt und Desaster jedenfalls und schwierig.
Und dann gerade in den kleineren Städten auch die Handwerker.
Also was ich da an Horror-Stories gehört habe, das geht auf keine Kuhhaut.
Aber ja, ist halt so.
Aber dafür, ja, auch wie gesagt, Leute ziehen halt oft um.
Deswegen gehört halt die Küche normalerweise mit zum Haus.
Also ist dann die ganzen Geräte, Ofen, Küche, Kühlschrank und so.
Ist dann eigentlich Teil des Hauses oftmals sogar Waschmaschine und Trockner,
aber generell die Küche.
Und du findest überall riesige Kühlschränke.
Natürlich kann man sich auch denken, also sie sind so ungefähr,
ich würde sagen, doppelt so groß wie im Schnitt bei uns.
Na, weil alles, was du da reinstellst, ist ja auch doppelt so groß wie bei uns.
Ja, das ist nämlich das andere Problem. So die Supermärkte, also es,
Angebot ist, teilweise überwältigend. Das ist ja bei uns teilweise schon nicht
schlecht, was es sich wird.
Aber dort ist es einfach nochmal eine Dimension obendrauf.
Supermärkte sind irgendwie auch zwei bis zehnmal so groß, wie man das irgendwie von hier kennt.
Preise,
Manche Sachen billiger als hier, aber das meiste deutlich teurer.
Also teilweise 50 bis 100 Prozent teurer, gerade so Sachen wie Gemüse.
Fleisch geht so, ist teilweise recht günstig, je nachdem.
Aber ja, also Paprika ist für mich immer so ein bisschen der Benchmark,
liegt dann so bei 1,50 Dollar ungefähr, so die Paprika beispielsweise.
Wie eine Paprika?
Eine Paprika, ja. Bei uns sind die auch ganz schön teuer geworden.
Also bei uns bist du auch je nachdem, 70 Cent bis auch einen Euro oder so für eine Paprika.
Eine Paprika, wirklich?
Mhm, mhm.
Also, aber ja, generell auch wieder, wie gesagt, extreme, extrem viel Fertiggerichte
und irgendwie Zeugs zum Zeitsparen.
Also da tut sich auch noch eine komplette neue Dimension an Inhaltsstoffen auf,
um schnell irgendwas zu generieren.
Zum Beispiel gibt es, ich habe jetzt vergessen, wie das Ding heißt,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das hier gibt, aber das ist eine Fertigpanade.
Also wenn du dann irgendwie ein paniertes Schnitzel oder so machen willst,
brauchst du kein Ei, brauchst du kein Mehl.
Es ist halt einfach so, das Zeug sieht aus wie Paniermehl, aber es ist halt irgendwie was anderes.
Das wälzte halt das einfach drin und fertig ist zum Beispiel.
Oder dann natürlich war es auch sehr schwierig, Mineralwasser zu bekommen.
Also generell einfach Wasser mit Kohlensäure ohne Geschmack.
Das gibt es dort praktisch nicht. Also es gibt das Ganze zum Mixen,
also das ist dann nicht in der Getränkeabteilung direkt,
sondern dann so meistens am Rand und gilt dann eher so als Barbedarf oder so, nämlich Soda.
Macht ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht Sinn, zumindest wenn man ordentliches Wasser
aus dem Trink, also die Trinkwasserqualität aus dem Wasserhahn erhält,
was jetzt vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer gegeben ist.
Ja, wobei Soda enthält dann auch noch irgendwie andere Inhaltsstoffe wegen Mixen
und Mineralwasser ist dann tatsächlich das.
Also es gibt auch Mineral Water. Aber ja, also Mineralwasser muss man wirklich
nachsuchen, aber dafür gibt es, und das jetzt ohne Übertreibung,
Hunderte von anderen Softgetränken im Supermarkt.
Also komplette Regale in allen Farben und Geschmacksrichtungen,
die man sich nur so vorstellen kann.
Und Energydrinks auch, ja, Sitzende von Marken.
Das kennen wir ja auch, dieses totale Überangebot von immer wieder dem gleichen Quatsch.
Ich meine nicht, dass sich das groß unterscheidet, aber es ist halt tausend
Farben und Varianten verfügbar for no reason.
Ja und Brot kannst du auch fast knicken, also was man dann isst sind Bagels,
aber so ich sag mal Brot, selbst im Supermarkt Brot geschnitten oder so,
also Brot ist einfach nicht in vielen Gegenden kein Thema.
Aber da musst du nicht erst in die USA fahren, um dieses Problem zu haben.
Das ist eine sehr deutsche Perspektive, wenn es ums Brot geht.
Mitteleuropa hat das so halbwegs auf der Kette, aber da bist du dann halt schon,
wenn du über Frankreich hinaus bist, dann wird es mit Brot schon dünner.
Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Naja. Ja. Aber es ist nicht so, dass sie Brot nicht kennen würden.
Also es gibt dort auch irgendwie Brot, aber offensichtlich ist es nicht so üblich.
Also dieses Brot, was wir essen oder was wir unter Brot verstehen,
ist dort eher nicht an der Tagesordnung.
Es ist halt Weißbrot.
Naja gut, lass uns mal hier nicht durch die alle Produktregale durchgehen Mich
würde ja ein bisschen mehr so interessieren, was dir sonst noch so aufgefallen
ist eigentlich so Man könnte jetzt natürlich tausend Sachen,
vergleichen, aber da kommen wir dann irgendwie auch nirgendwo hin.
Also was mir aufgefallen ist, ich weiß nicht, ob das auch daran liegt,
dass ich jetzt alt werde oder, aber es war unglaublich laut in diesem Land Also,
Also klar gibt es auch irgendwie im Wald, findest du eine Stelle, wo es ruhig ist.
Aber selbst da, wie gesagt, Züge fahren halt überall vorbei.
Also in der Natur hörst du dann öfter Züge pfeifen.
Aber ansonsten natürlich die Autos. In manchen Staaten gibt es kein TÜV und
die Leute haben offensichtlich Spaß daran,
ihre Schalldämpfer auszubauen und dann mit besonders lauten Autos in der Gegend rumzufahren.
Das ist mir vor allem in Texas aufgefallen.
Und dann werkeln an vielen Stellen irgendwelche Maschinchen oder Motoren,
natürlich allem voran Klimaanlagen, von denen die Hälfte schlecht gewartet sind
und dann vor sich hin klappern.
Aber auch alle möglichen anderen Lüftungsanlagen und Pumpen und Transformatoren
und Lkw, die rückwärts fahren.
Also es ist mir einfach aufgefallen, fast egal, Rasenmäher ist auch so ein Ding.
Also speziell in Washington hatten wir...
Oder Lautbläser.
Ja, zudem Lautbläser, genau. Lautbläser ist tatsächlich auch ein Ding natürlich,
aber gut, das kennen wir alle.
Aber ja, es ist dort einfach laut.
Und wenn also Menschen in der Nähe sind, ist es halt laut.
Und meine Theorie war jetzt, warum die Amerikaner oft so laut sprechen,
ist schlichtweg, weil es in diesem Land so laut ist.
Und wenn sie nicht so laut reden würden, könnte sie niemand verstehen,
weil sie irgendwie durch den Lärm durchdringen wollen.
Okay.
Das kann doch nicht die einzige Erklärung sein, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht. Aber das war jetzt sozusagen meine These.
Weil mir das aufgefallen ist, das ist tatsächlich einfach die Hintergrundgeräusche.
Meistens, selbst wenn du in einem Restaurant sitzt, dann ist der Parkplatz nebenbei.
Also wenn du draußen sitzt und die Autobahn ist dann gleich nebenbei. und ja.
Die Wände sind dünn.
Die Leute am Nachbartisch reden
alle laut und so setzt sich das dann fort und ja, es ist einfach laut.
Und es gibt natürlich keine Sonntagsruhe und keine Mittagsruhe. Es ist halt ja.
Auch völlig alles ist immer offen.
Das Konzept, ja.
Interessante These. Also müssen wir mal mit anderen Ländern vergleichen,
wo es auch ziemlich laut ist.
Weil das ist ja wirklich nicht nur in den USA so, sondern generell,
wo viel Verkehr ist und so weiter, da ist es laut.
Aber es heißt ja nicht, dass sich gleich alle mal so anschreien müssen.
Ja, nein. Da habe ich schon erwähnt, in Bahnlinien. Also es gibt unglaublich viele Bahnlinien.
Das Gefühl in den USA.
Und teilweise auch, manchmal hast du eine Autobahn, die läuft 100 Kilometer
nur geradeaus, ohne Kurve.
Und dann hast du rechts daneben eine Eisenbahn, die fährt auch 100 Kilometer geradeaus.
Das auch auf. Und dann, wie gesagt, aber selbst in den kleinsten,
abgelegensten Orten siehst du auf einmal, ja, fahren riesige Züge,
die sind dann auch mehrere Kilometer lang teilweise.
Und das Nette ist dann, weil es da eine Menge unbeschränkte Bahnübergänge gibt,
ist, dass sie dann vor jedem unbeschränkten Bahnübergang natürlich die Huppe ziehen.
Also ich habe nie so viele Züge pfeifen hören wie in dieser Zeit in den USA,
in den letzten 20 Jahren nicht.
Ja, stimmt. Das gehört auch so ein bisschen zu einer klassischen amerikanischen
Geräuschkulisse, die man so im Kopf hat.
Ja, und sonst, was auch auffällt, also neben Straßen und äh,
In Eisenbahnen findest du auch überall Stromstraßen.
Also Stromleitungen scheinen auch überall hinzugehen und das auch in oft abgelegenen Gegenden.
Und natürlich viele Überlandleitungen auch in Städten und so.
Und dann habe ich mal auch rumgefragt, was die Leute denn so eigentlich an Strom bezahlen.
Und in vielen den Gegenden ist er jetzt auch deutlich teurer geworden.
Also manche Leute meinten, ihre Stromrechnungen hätten sich verdoppelt seit dem letzten Jahr.
Aber generell ist Strom eher billig, also zwischen den billigsten Ländern so
um die 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde.
Aber in Kalifornien herrschen praktisch deutsche Strompreise,
so mit 35, 40 Cent pro Kilowattstunde.
Das ist auch wieder sehr regional unterschiedlich.
Und ja, der Stromverbrauch ist natürlich...
Wobei Kalifornien wahrscheinlich im Mittel eine höhere Kaufkraft hat.
Ja, ja, ja, ich meine da, okay. Ich habe dann ein paar Freunde besucht,
die so im Silicon Valley bei unter
anderem Google oder anderen typischen kalifornischen Firmen arbeiten.
Und ja, habe dann gefragt, was sie denn so verdienen aktuell.
Also jetzt keine hohen Manager, sondern normale Mitarbeiter.
IT- oder Kreativbereich und so das Standardgehalt aktuell im Silicon Valley für,
jetzt bei Google beispielsweise oder auch bei anderen Startups ist,
dass du 300.000 im Jahr, also 300.000 Dollar im Jahr in Cash und 300.000 Dollar im Jahr in Optionen.
Also das ist so sozusagen normal.
25.000 Dollar pro Monat.
Mhm.
Und dann nochmal 25.000 Dollar in Aktien?
Ja.
Pro Monat.
Das ist immer eine Menge Holz.
Mhm.
Aber es ist halt auch teuer dort.
Aber ja, damit kommt man ganz gut hin in Kalifornien.
Aber das ist doch jetzt, also wir reden jetzt hier nicht von einem,
also das ist jetzt Startup-Kohle, Tech-Geld.
Google, ja, Google. Das eine ist Google.
Ja, okay, aber nicht Average-Worker,
irgendwie Durchschnittsgehalt in Kalifornien oder so.
Nee, nee, nee. Durchschnittsgehalt wahrscheinlich liegt eher so bei 100.
Also Einkommengut, Durchschnitt, das müsste man natürlich auf den Median gucken.
Aber davon geben Sie 5.000 schon mal aus für die Wohnung, ne?
Ja, zwischen 2 und 4, je nachdem. Fürs Wohnen, ja. 2.000 bis 4.000 Dollar.
2.000 hast du dann,
ein, anderthalb Zimmer irgendwo im Silicon Valley, aber für,
drei bis viertausend kriegst du auch schon ein ordentliches Räuschen,
so mit drei, vier Zimmern und Garten und so irgendwo im Valley.
Das ist nicht mitten in San Francisco.
Aber die anderen 20.000, die musst du dann wahrscheinlich für deine Krankenversicherung aufbringen.
Also Krankenversicherung,
weil die Privaten sind günstiger als in Deutschland.
Du hast dann andere Modelle,
aber tatsächlich private Krankenversicherungen in Deutschland bist du jetzt
bei 700, 800 Euro im Monat.
Das ist immer noch günstiger, als wenn du Arbeitnehmer- und Arbeitgeberanteil,
von der gesetzlichen bezahlst, aber die gesetzliche ist dann halt einkommensabhängig.
Und während natürlich in den
USA, gut, es gibt zig verschiedene Versorgungssysteme und Versicherungen.
Und insbesondere aber, wenn du fürs Militär oder für den öffentlichen Dienst
arbeitest, ist deine Krankenversicherung quasi kostenlos.
Also da wird nicht mal ein Arbeitnehmerbeitrag oder so eingezogen.
Oder du kannst dich zwischen, ja, weiß nicht, liegen, also meistens liegen die
zwischen 50 und 100 Euro pro Monat, die Beiträge.
Und ich habe halt mit Leuten gesprochen, was die so zahlen, wenn sie denn versichert sind.
Und ja, also die monatlichen, also die Beiträge waren in der Regel deutlich
günstiger als bei der deutschen privaten Krankenkasse.
Also ich habe auch schon, ja, deutsche Krankenkassen können natürlich auch eine ganze Menge abrufen.
Ja.
Ich glaube, der Spitzenbeitrag sogar bei den normalen liegt jetzt auch schon so bei 900 bis 1000.
Ja, ja, ja. Und so viel zahlt in den USA niemand für seine Krankenhäuser.
Ja, aber du hast natürlich auch überhaupt nicht dieselbe Deckung,
wie wir das hier gewohnt sind.
Wenn du das hier bezahlst, dann bist du ja im Wesentlichen safe.
Da kann ja irgendwie passieren, was du willst. dann kannst du irgendwie vier
Wochen im Krankenhaus liegen und drei Stunden irgendwie mit dem Krankenwagen
durch die Stadt gefahren werden.
Mit der Krankenversicherung in den USA hast du immer das Problem, dass,
alles irgendwie so deductibles hast, du musst überall nochmal was zahlen und
vor allem werden halt für bestimmte Maßnahmen gelten dann die Krankenversicherungen
nicht, wenn es so richtig teuer wird und dann wird es auch gleich so richtig teuer, also so,
fünfstellig, sechsstellig teuer.
Ja, es sei denn, Du bist irgendwie im öffentlichen Dienst oder bist Familienangehöriger
von jemandem im öffentlichen Dienst.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn du halt jetzt verwitwet bist und dein Partner war mal Soldat,
dann bist du bis ans Lebensende kostenlos krankenversichert zum Beispiel.
Ja, noch.
Noch. Ich will sagen, ich sage jetzt nicht, dass jetzt die USA ein Sozialparadies wären oder so.
Und ja, mit den Zuzahlungen und so.
Aber es gibt halt eben keine Versicherungspflicht, was dazu führt,
dass viele Leute eben Probleme kriegen.
Plus, dann gibt es halt viele dieser günstigen Versicherungen,
aber nicht alle haben dann halt höhere Zuzahlungen oder Deckungsobergrenzen.
Die hast du in Deutschland nicht. Also in Deutschland öffentliche Versicherungen
zahlt sogar das Höchste, was glaube ich,
Im letzten Jahr, die eine Krankenversicherung, eine öffentliche,
für einen Patienten bezahlt hat, waren 50 Millionen Euro an Kosten.
Aber das machen die dann auch, wenn es denn sein muss.
Da gibt es quasi offensichtlich keine Obergrenze in Deutschland.
Lass uns mal ein bisschen zu den Leuten selber kommen.
Also ich meine auch da mag sich das natürlich extrem unterscheiden.
Aber wir wissen ja alle, derzeit geht es richtig rund in den USA und es gibt diese,
gesellschaftliche Spaltung, glaube ich, die man herbeireden kann,
aber die sicherlich dort auch spürbar ist.
Also gerade die Unterscheidung zwischen Demokraten und Republikaner,
aber sicherlich halt nicht nur das.
Ja, also es ist alles deutlich rauer und kompetitiver.
Also es fängt schon damit an, ich meine die Arbeitskultur ist eine andere,
also die Ausbeutung ist deutlich größer, weil die Gewerkschaften halt auch teilweise
nicht existent oder schwach sind und weil die Gesetze zum,
Arbeitnehmerschutz gering sind.
Aber dadurch eben auch ist die Kultur eine andere.
Es ist auch ein anderes Selbstverständnis, glaube ich. Dieses Leben,
Arbeiten ist sozusagen der Default. Und Urlaub überhaupt zu erhalten in der
Arbeit ist schon mal was Besonderes und wenn, dann ist es nur sehr wenig und schon gar nicht,
die Menge, die wir hier in Europa gewohnt sind.
Aber es ist glaube ich auch so, dass viele selbst die Arbeitszeiten,
selbst die Urlaubstage, die ihnen zustehen, nicht vollständig abrufen,
weil es so ein Stigma gibt, dass wenn du jetzt sozusagen nicht arbeitest,
dass du dann sozusagen deine Coworker im Stich lässt.
Ja, ich meine das perverseste sind die Sick Days.
Das ist sozusagen auch eine Quote, eine bestimmte Anzahl an Tagen,
die du nehmen kannst, wenn du krank bist.
Wenn die aber weg sind, musst du halt normale Urlaubstage einsetzen und wenn
die weg sind, gibt es keine Lotfortzahlung mehr, wirst du nicht bezahlt.
Weswegen es dann so Dinge gibt, wo dann aufgerufen wird hier für den Kollegen
und so, der ist jetzt so lange krank, wollt ihr nicht eure Sickdays spenden,
damit der weiter bezahlt werden kann. So solche Dinge.
Und dann generell verbringen die Leute auch mehr Zeit auf der Arbeit.
Also arbeiten In dem Sinne eher 40 bis 50 Stunden in der Woche.
Aber dafür geht viel Zeit, auch von diesen 40 bis 50 Stunden,
auf Smalltalk und andere Dinge.
Gut, kommt auf den Job an natürlich. Aber gerade in vielen Bürojobs und so ist
ein signifikanter Teil der Arbeitszeit oft Socializing oder ja...
Was ja darum heißt, dass auch die Arbeit sozusagen auch Teil deines sozialen Lebens ist.
Ja, das scheint wichtig zu sein.
Aber es ist halt auch so, es herrscht halt viel Misstrauen.
Es ist halt sehr viel Wettbewerb in den Firmen auch um Beförderung oder so.
Oder auch im akademischen Bereich und so. Das ist teilweise wirklich unangenehm.
Aber es gibt eben auch genau das Gegenteil.
Wie gesagt, öffentlicher Dienst, Militär ist auch ein gutes Beispiel,
wo es nicht viel anders ist als teilweise hier und wo du auch dann Mitarbeiter
hast, die einfach unzufrieden sind und sich hängen lassen und einfach nichts
tun, aber in der Regel nicht gekündigt werden können.
Das sind aber nicht die, die jetzt von Musk gefeuert wurden,
sondern da gingen jetzt diese Doge-Entlassungen, hingen davon ab.
Wie deine Abteilung heißt, für die du gerade arbeitest.
Die hatten halt nichts mit dir persönlich zu tun.
Aber wehe, du hattest irgendwas mit Umweltschutz oder mit Gleichstellung oder
so zu tun oder mit Entwicklungshilfe.
Dann bist du halt gefeuert worden.
Unabhängig davon, was du vorher gemacht hast oder vielleicht danach hättest
machen sollen, das ja mitbekommen.
Also viele Leute waren tatsächlich auch wegen Doge und so extrem besorgt und
eine ganze Menge hat es dann auch durchaus getroffen.
Die wurden dann jetzt geriffed, wie das so schön heißt, im öffentlichen Dienst.
Geriffed?
Ja.
Was, woraus leistet sich das ab? Riffing?
Reduction in Force.
Reduction in Force. Ah, R-I-F einfach nur A. Okay, verstehe.
Ja, aber die reden dann von wurde geriffed.
Geriffed, okay.
Riffed, ja. So. So.
Aber ich meine, wie kam denn so die Gesellschaft so vor?
Also ich meine, du hast dich ja mit Leuten unterhalten und du wirst ja vielleicht
auch mal auf die allgemeinen Probleme gerade angesprochen haben.
Was war so dein Eindruck?
Also vor allem jüngere Leute, tatsächlich so unter 30,
sind ganz schön am Straucheln wegen Wohnung und Job zu finden.
Das heißt, ein großer Teil, der dann in irgendwelchen Wohnwagensiedlungen oder bei den Eltern oder so,
weil du brauchst halt schon selbst als einzelne Person in den USA,
irgendwo am Stadtrand von, ich sag mal,
Dallas oder so für ein Zimmer oder ein kleines Apartment, so bis zu ab 1500 oder bist du dabei.
Und dann wird auch oft verlangt noch, dass es einen Bürgen gibt und einen Auszug
aus einem Strafregister da so und und und.
Also selbst quasi, wenn du das Geld hast oder hättest, gibt es da noch dann
andere Hürden, jetzt ein Apartment zu mieten beispielsweise.
Und dann sind die.
Teilweise die Mietverträge sind auch einfach unterirdisch,
wozu du dich da bereit erklären musst und alle auch in der Regel befristet so
erstmal auf sechs bis zwölf Monate und die müssen dann verlängert werden und
dann können die alle sechs bis zwölf Monate beim Neuabschluss dann die Miete
auch wieder erhöhen und so.
Also das ist vor allem das Problem bei jungen Leuten.
Jobs gibt es zwar viele, aber viele der Jobs sind halt dann schlecht bezahlt
und ohne Sozialleistungen und oft auch so unter der Hand.
Und also hilft es nicht den Leuten, jetzt irgendwie den jungen Leuten,
wirklich eine Existenz zu gründen.
Und ist nicht bei allen so, aber es ist hart.
Ich habe wirklich Leute kennengelernt, die gut ausgebildet sind,
ordentlich sind, sich fleißig sind.
Und ja, trotzdem an der Grenze zur Obdachlosigkeit eigentlich unterwegs sind.
Nicht nur ein Einzelfall, sondern ich habe mehrfach bemerkt.
Ja, dann auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt,
Silicon Valley-Freunde mit 300.000 Dollar oder 25.000 Dollar im Monat kamen
ganz entspannt über die Runden.
Kein Wunder.
Guten Eindruck. Ja, und dann hast du so,
ich sage mal, ältere Leute in meinem Alter, so zwischen 50 und 60 irgendwo in der Gegend und,
die,
schienen fast alle irgendwie krank zu sein.
Also hatten halt typische fünf bis zehn Pillen am Morgen und dann alle möglichen
seltsamen Krankheiten,
gegen die diese Pillen helfen sollten.
Meistens überwiegen natürlich Zivilisationserkrankungen.
Und ja, Alkohol ist durchaus auch ein Thema.
Also Alkoholismus ist in bestimmten Bereichen, in bestimmten sozialen Schichten
auch sehr ausgeprägt. insbesondere im öffentlichen Dienst beziehungsweise beim Militär.
Also ich habe tatsächlich ein halbes Dutzend Militärangehöriger,
kenne ich so deren Geschichte und alle haben Alkoholprobleme oder hatten Alkoholprobleme. oder, ja.
Das ist auch eine These, warum.
Gut, Militär wird, also beim Bund wurde auch viel gesoffen und so.
Und Alkohol und Militär scheint einfach irgendwie eine unheilige Allianz zu sein.
Also jetzt gar nicht so ein amerikanisches, keine spezifische amerikanische
Eigenschaft, weil ich meine, bei den Russen wird bestimmt auch ordentlich gesoffen.
Ja, also es ist mir dort halt einfach nur aufgefallen, auch weil aber das amerikanische
Militär, weil dort einfach sehr viele Leute, ich das Gefühl hatte,
irgendwie, ja,
eine militärische Karriere hatten oder zumindest in dem Umfeld,
in dem ich mich bewegt habe, hatte irgendwie jeder einen Militärangehörigen.
Also das Ding ist auch, dass wenn du im Staatsdienst bist, weil die Leute oft
im Ausland Dienst leisten,
dass du dann, wenn du deinen Partner mitnimmst, der halt bevorzugt eingestellt wird.
Das heißt, du hast halt oft ganze Familien, die aufgrund dessen dann im Staatsdienst
oder beim Militär sind, weil ein Angehöriger oder der Ehepartner beim Militär
ist und das ist auch verbreitet.
Und, das ist halt attraktiv, weil nach 20 Jahren Dienst bist du pensionsberechtigt
und kannst dich dann, wenn du 50 Jahre alt bist, in Rente gehen.
So, wenn du 20 Jahre im Staatsdienst warst.
Das ist ja alles ganz schön. Aber die Leute, die jetzt im Staatsdienst sind,
das ist ja nun wirklich auch ein bisschen die Ausnahme. Also das ist irgendwie eine Minderheit.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, auch diese Leute, also die Leute schienen mir alle krank
zu sein. Unabhängig von dem, was sie machen sozusagen.
Die Älteren unabhängig, was sie machen und ja, also nicht gesund.
Was mich jetzt mal viel mehr noch interessieren würde, ist so,
wie siehst du das Verhältnis der Amerikaner zu ihrem Staat und auch der Gesellschaft gegenüber?
Das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen so das, was uns ja am meisten Fragezeichen
in den Kopf projiziert, weil wir einfach mit unserem Verständnis,
mit unserem Selbstverständnis auch von Gesellschaft und Zusammenhalt und was
der Staat ist und was er für uns tun soll,
offensichtlich ja auf einer ganz anderen Linie liegen. Also es gibt auch in
Europa noch extremere Beispiele,
aber so grundsätzlich geht es ja alles mehr oder weniger in diese Richtung bei
uns, zumindest im Westeuropa und vor allem im Norden, etwas weniger im Süden vielleicht.
Wir sind der Staat und der Staatsapparat ist unsere Serviceagentur,
die aus unseren Steuern, die wir gerne zahlen, alles irgendwie organisiert und
baut und macht und zusammenhält.
Und das sind irgendwie wir. Und wenn ich auf die USA schaue,
habe ich das Gefühl, diese Wir-Symbolik, die existiert da gar nicht so sehr.
Die existiert nur im Konfliktfall.
Jetzt führen wir einen Krieg, wir gegen die anderen. Also mehr so ein Wir,
nur wenn es um alle anderen geht aber nicht so dieses wir sind ein ich habe fast gesagt,
wir sind ein Volk also diese Mentalität dass es den Staat gibt weil das gut
ist das ist eher sehr verbreitet und speziell natürlich bei den Republikanern
ein Stück weit auch irgendwie bei allen dass so der Staat wird eher so, naja,
okay Militär und so, ein paar Sachen und Grenzen, das muss man irgendwie die auch darüber regeln.
Aber mischt euch mal nicht so ein.
Also das Individuum sieht sich da sozusagen fern vom Staat und den Staat eher
als störend an. Das ist jetzt mal meine These.
Kannst mir ja vielleicht mal deine Eindrücke schildern, inwiefern du das noch so...
Ja, also mein Eindruck war, dass...
Ja, die Leute lieber ihr eigenes Ding machen, ihren eigenen Kuchen backen,
tendenziell eher auch mehr Abstand zu Nachbarn lieber haben,
obwohl in kleineren Communities der nachbarschaftliche Zusammenhalt und so,
der dörfliche Zusammenhalt ist auf jeden Fall ein Ding,
wo ich das Gefühl habe, Das ist genauso ausgeprägt wie hier oder ausgeprägter.
Aber die Distanzen sind natürlich größer. Die Leute leben nicht so dicht aufeinander.
Das mögen sie auch nicht. und sie zahlen sehr ungern Steuern.
Also sie empfinden nicht das Gegut hier, ich meine, niemand zahlt wirklich gerne
Steuern, aber man versucht eigentlich oft, wo es geht.
Das zu vermeiden, bis hin zu, dass manche Leute absichtlich in Gegenden wohnen,
wo sie selber für die Straße zuständig sind und keinen Strom haben und so.
Und was aber ziemlich übel ist im Übrigen. Also diese privat gepflegten Straßen
und Schotterwege, das ist die Hölle.
Das funktioniert vorne und hinten nicht so richtig. ich, das hast du dann.
Und das hast du dann halt auch. Und es gibt die Einstellung zu Regeln und Gesetzen,
das ist einfach grundsätzlich anders.
In Deutschland guckt man schon mehr auf Regeln und sieht eventuell auch den Sinn ein.
Oder dann hast du auch die Leute, die natürlich auf die Einhaltung von Regeln pochen.
Und in den USA ist man nicht so besessen von Regeln oder der Einhaltung von Regeln,
sondern da werden sie oft einfach auch schlichtweg ignoriert.
Weil Staat ist weit weg und Polizeidichte ist gering.
Und ja, also es ist dann mehr,
wie man das vielleicht hier als südländische Mentalität bezeichnen würde,
was so jetzt Regeln angeht oder Ordnung und Sauberkeit und so.
Aber es gibt dann natürlich auch wiederum das andere Extrem,
so Gated Communities und Hauseigentümergemeinschaften oder HOAs,
die dann wieder total krasse Regeln haben,
die sich hier niemand gefallen lassen würde.
H.O.A. Homeowner Association.
H.O.A. Gemeinschaft, die dir dann die Länge des Rasens vorschreiben und die Art der Pflanzen,
die du in deinem Garten haben darfst und die Beschaffenheit der Zäune usw.
Hier gibt es auch so etwas wie Gemeindesatzungen, aber.
Das sind vor allem noch mal so private Unternehmen meistens,
die dann da sozusagen engagiert werden und dann die Leute, die da wohnen, auch terrorisieren.
Gab es mal einen schönen Bericht von John Oliver darüber, der war schon etwas grausig.
Ja, und dann Orte, also auch Städte sind dann inkorporiert,
also quasi eine eigene Städte können quasi eine eigene juristische Person sein,
müssen aber nicht.
Beziehungsweise kann es dann sein dass Städte einfach sich austragen lassen, weil,
zu wenig Leute da oder sagt halt okay und wir sind ab sofort jetzt keine Stadt
mehr dann rechtlich, dann gibt es halt quasi auch,
rechtlich niemanden dann gibt es halt nur noch den Landkreis aber der ist für
bestimmte Dinge nicht zuständig das heißt die wohnen dann einfach irgendwo und
du hast dann dort eben gewisse,
Zuständigkeitslücken dann, beziehungsweise niemanden, der sich dann um die Infrastruktur kümmert.
Also sie müssen sich dann selber um ihre Straßen und was auch immer kümmern und ja.
Das ist der wilde Westen. Ich meine, so stellt man sich das ja auch vor und ich glaube,
oder ich habe den Eindruck, dass das für viele auch ganz okay ist.
Also, dass das sozusagen so ein Trade-off ist, weil diese Vorstellung,
also es dreht sich ja immer um dieses Wort Freiheit.
Ja.
Und alle schreien das. Und es ist halt nur so, dass,
jetzt mal im direkten Vergleich zu Europa,
die Amerikaner einfach, glaube ich, eine ganz andere Vorstellung davon haben,
was das bedeutet, Freiheit.
Bei denen ist es halt im Wesentlichen Freiheit von allem.
Ich will hier selber machen und es hat keine Behörde zu geben,
die mir jetzt vorschreibt, wie mein Auto ist.
Und ich kann da ranflanschen und rannageln, was ich will und mit den absurdesten
Konstruktionen durch die Weltgeschichte fahren, weil wer bist du denn,
dass du das irgendwie für mich entscheiden willst,
wie ich mein Auto zusammenschraube oder woraus das besteht oder was das für
einen Motor hat oder irgendwas.
Und wenn ich da vorne so ein Kuhhorn dran ballern will, dann mache ich das halt
einfach, weil es sieht geil aus.
Das ist so diese Vorstellung. Und unsere Form von Freiheit ist halt sehr viel mehr geprägt durch ein,
Freiheit im Sinne von Sicherheit.
Sicherheit primär jetzt im, also was heißt primär, von allem so ein bisschen,
also Sicherheit im eigentlichen Sinne, Sicherheit vor Gefährdung, vor Kriminalität,
so Sachen, aber eben auch die Freiheit abgesichert zu sein.
Also Krankenversicherung, solche sozialen Systeme,
Auffang, weil es ja auch für mich gut ist, wenn es anderen Leuten gut geht,
weil dann hast du nicht diese Verrohungs- und Ausschlussmomente,
die halt in den USA dann doch häufig zu sehen sind.
Es ist ja alles sehr an diesem American Dream.
Man muss es ja nur wollen und wenn du es nicht geschafft hast,
dann hast du es wohl nicht genug gewollt.
Was dann aber automatisch verbunden ist, ist dann eben auch so mit so einer
Ausgrenzung, weil wenn du es nicht geschafft hast, dann bist du halt auch nichts
wert und dann wohnst du halt unter der Brücke oder was weiß ich.
Ist mir egal, du hast ja nichts mit mir zu tun, du bist ja so zufällig auf demselben Land unterwegs,
aber hier ist mein Home-Turf, hier ist unsere Region und was irgendwelche Regierungen
tausende Kilometer von hier entfernt,
so mein, das ficht mich nicht an.
Das ist so ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung des Ganzen.
Man muss natürlich auch hier dazu sagen, dass das eine grobe Verallgemeinerung
ist und es auch regional extrem unterschiedlich sein kann.
Du findest einfach auch Gegenden und soziale Schichten und Leute,
wo du das Gefühl hast, die unterscheiden sich jetzt nicht allzu sehr von Europa.
Also es gibt, sagen wir auch, europäische oder europäisierte Amerikaner durchaus und Gegenden.
Ich meine nicht, alle sind anders und es ist auf jeden Fall immer anders,
sondern es ist einfach eine Meta-Betrachtung der Gesellschaft,
einfach auch mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie ist deren Verhältnis dazu.
Also ich meine, wir sitzen ja hier und fragen uns die ganze Zeit,
Leute, Trump, geht's noch?
Und gehen dabei natürlich irgendwie davon aus, dass wir dieselbe Nähe zu diesem
politischen System dort haben.
Dass es dort dieselbe Nähe zu diesem politischen System gibt, was es so nicht gibt.
Oder dass auch nur dieselben Erwartungshaltungen an dieses politische System
gestellt werden. Was offensichtlich ja nicht so ist.
Und dieses Lasst uns in Ruhe hat halt auch viel mit, wir lassen auch die in Ruhe.
Und wenn sie es nicht total übertreiben oder wenn ich nicht davon betroffen
bin, dann ist es mir auch egal. Ich habe jetzt gerade so ein paar Berichte gesehen.
Diese ganzen Zollentscheidungen von Trump ruinieren ja gerade zum Beispiel die
Farmer auch in diesen Red States, die eigentlich republikanisch gewählt haben,
so Dakota, Norddakota, Süddakota, also so Regionen, die leben einfach nur von
Agrar und von nichts anderem.
Und dadurch, dass sie jetzt halt einerseits ihre ganzen Aufträge verlieren,
weil sie durch die Zölle jetzt einfach ihr Zeug, ihr Soja nicht mehr loswerden,
die Exporte nach China, alle storniert werden auf der einen Seite und auf der
anderen Seite durch diese harte Migrationspolitik ihnen auch noch die Arbeiter
weglaufen und sie niemanden haben,
verrotten jetzt da gerade ihre Felder und sie haben keine Aufträge und können
das irgendwie alles gar nicht mehr so schaffen.
Und müssen halt, gehen halt bankrott.
Und dann guckst du dir an, wie sie da weinerlich in die Kameras reinschreien
und das irgendwie auf TikTok hochladen, wie entsetzt sie doch so sind.
Und eine sagte halt, ja sie würde das ja gar nicht verstehen,
weil hier hätten doch alle Republikaner gewählt und wenn doch hier alle Republikaner
gewählt haben, dann müssten die doch auch was für uns tun.
Und da lässt sich natürlich schön ablesen, wie so diese Mentalität ist.
Nicht so, oh wir müssen die Richtigen wählen, damit die richtige Politik gemacht
wird insgesamt, sondern ein, ja wir wählen euch, weil ihr seid ja immer für uns.
Und wenn ihr für uns seid, ist es gut.
Genau, du hast es gesagt.
Hat ein bisschen was davon. Wo man die Bayern nicht ganz so aus dem Garten treten,
aber die Mentalität spürt man da auch so ein bisschen.
Also was mir aufgefallen ist, ich habe natürlich nach Protestenausschau gehalten,
vor allem, und keine gesehen.
Nicht mal in Washington. Es waren wohl welche, aber es ist halt einfach so groß
und ich habe sie nicht gefunden.
Also da muss man dann tatsächlich suchen und dann findet man auch die Proteste,
aber es war nicht so wie in Berlin, wo ich, ja,
fast egal in welcher zentralen Straße ich sitze, irgendwie alle paar Wochen
kommt irgendwie mal eine Demo direkt bei mir vom Fenster lang.
Und Und dann ist es so, dass auch einen Großteil der Leute hatte ich das Gefühl,
Interessiert sich nicht für Politik wirklich. Die sind depolitisiert.
Das ist bei uns auch der Fall. Aber wenn du dir die Wahlbeteiligung anguckst
und speziell Wahlbeteiligung bei kleineren Wahlen, hast du manchmal 10,
20 Prozent oder so, die wählen gehen.
Und wählen ist auch teilweise echt umständlich dort und selbst jetzt bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl, habe ich was, 60 Prozent Wahlbeteiligung irgendwo in der Gegend.
Das war schon viel.
Und ja und was ich so gehört habe so an Meinungen war zum Beispiel ja, ob Trump oder Harris,
ist doch egal die ziehen uns beide ja, ist doch egal die machen eh alle was
sie wollen und sind eh von der Industrielobby gekauft und.
Meine Stimme hat sowieso keine Auswirkung.
Das ist bei ganz, ganz vielen Leuten, auch viele jüngere Leute,
sind einfach komplett disillusioniert von der Politik und versuchen einfach
in ihrem Umfeld, in ihrem Rahmen was zu machen, aber sehen nicht,
dass irgendwie die Politik da irgendeinen Unterschied macht.
Was leider auch eine falsche Betrachtung ist, Das ist aber nicht völlig falsch,
weil natürlich das politische System der USA ist bisweilen auch ziemlich katastrophal.
Also allein schon die Gliederung, diese 50 Bundesstaaten.
Manche Bundesstaaten haben irgendwie weniger oder eine ganze Reihe von Bundesstaaten
haben halt weniger Bevölkerung als zwei Berliner Bezirke.
Und in diesen Ländern, Hauptstadt selbst Delaware, Wilmington,
80.000 Einwohner, wie Lüdenscheid ungefähr.
Das ist dann so die Hauptstadt von einem amerikanischen Bundesstaat.
Oder sich Montana auch, glaube ich, die Hauptstadt.
Boßmann oder so der größeren Orte alle so unter 100.000 also nicht mehr,
was mir sagen würde Mittelstädte nicht mal Großstädte sind halt dann dort die
Hauptstädte und das führt natürlich auch dazu Helena ist die Hauptstadt von Montana,
Helena ist die Hauptstadt Helena und hat was?
32.000.
32.000, ja. Das ist, ich meine...
Und Delaware heißt die Hauptstadt Dover.
Eigentlich ist es Wilmington, dachte ich, von Delaware müsste Wilmington sein.
Hauptstadt des Bundesstaates Delaware.
Okay. Und?
39.000 und Metropolregion 181.000.
Dein Wilmington ist, glaube ich, nicht die Hauptstadt.
Okay, dann war es nur die größte Stadt vielleicht in Delaware mit 80.000.
Einwohnern. Ja, es ist die größte Stadt und die hat 70.800.
Da sind im Übrigen die Hälfte aller amerikanischen Aktiengesellschaften dort
gemeldet. Also hat die einen Firmensitz.
Oh Mann, oh Mann.
Oh Mann.
Delaware hat irgendwie noch nicht mal eine Million.
Und jetzt hast du halt diese ganzen Bundesstaaten, wo eine Handvoll Leute nur sind.
Und deswegen ist die Qualität an politischem Personal, also insgesamt der Topf,
aus dem du schöpfen kannst, ist halt...
Überschaubar. Das ist halt klein
und das führt dann natürlich auch zu entsprechend seltsamen Gesetzen.
Also dagegen ist dann wahrscheinlich das Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus eine Ausgeburt
an Kompetenz verglichen mit einfach manchen amerikanischen Landesparlamenten.
Ich meine, in Berlin hat man mindestens vier Millionen Leute,
aus denen man irgendwie sich sein Personal aussuchen kann.
Während du dann in so einer Hauptstadt von so einem Bundesstaat hast du irgendwie 30.000 Leute.
Und da musst du dann Parlamentarier...
Ich würde da Berlin überhaupt nicht die Freischein geben, weil hier ist es wirklich schlimm.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber kein Vergleich.
Und dann halt auch wiederum ist dieses föderale System,
in Deutschland sind wir halt viel, viel einheitlicher, was so Gesetze angeht
und auch unser Grundgesetz und so funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Aber also sorgt dafür, dass es so eine gewisse Einheitlichkeit gibt,
was die rechtliche Situation angeht.
Während man.
Ja, in den USA, Verkehr ist komplett anders,
andere Gesetze, was die Zulassung von Autos angeht, was irgendwie das Bauen
angeht und so weiter und gesagt,
nur am Rande, ich meine die Marihuana-Gesetzgebung ist auch eine komplette Katastrophe,
ohne da jetzt ins Detail zu gehen, Aber wir denken, okay,
ja, da gibt es gewisse Staaten, da ist Marihuana legal, kennen wir ja,
Kalifornien, Washington war der erste Staat, andere nicht.
Aber was ich weiß, ist,
dass es dann so Dinge gibt, wie zum Beispiel in Alaska dürfen legal nur Amerikaner kiffen.
So als Ausländer, du hast dann so Gesetze, die halt dann für Ausländer besonders diskriminieren.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt immer, ich finde, wir machen es so ein bisschen einfach,
wenn wir sagen, hier die USA und da Deutschland und unsere Bundesländer sind
ja so und die Bundesstaaten sind so.
Man muss es wirklich mit Europa insgesamt vergleichen.
Und rechtliche, also unterschiedliche Ansichten darüber, wie das Verhältnis
zum Staat ist, wenn man von Portugal,
bis nach Finnland und nach Griechenland gehst, da wirst du natürlich auch sehr
diverses Auffassungen darüber finden, wie das alles so richtig verhält.
Und in dem Sinne, was das Chaos angeht,
so steht, oder Unterschiede, ja,
steht es teilweise Europa in nichts nach,
so, beziehungsweise was so die Uneinheitlichkeit vieler Dinge angeht.
Da hat man das Gefühl, dass Europa mittlerweile zumindest, zumindest was die
rechtliche Situation angeht, deutlich einheitlicher ist.
Aber ja, es sind natürlich überall andere Verwaltungen und Gesundheitssysteme und, und, und.
Insofern, die andere Sache ist,
dass es wohl bei der Befragung, welches Land Leute am besten finden,
ist es überwiegend das Land, wo sie aufgewachsen sind.
Und ja, das ist das Normal.
Das ist das, so wie es sein sollte eigentlich. Und da gibt es nur wenige Länder
auf der Welt, die wirklich so kaputt sind, wo die Leute dann sagen,
ja, nee, auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie so wie in meinem Land.
Aber so selbst in China oder so, sagen die Leute, nee, China ist einfach das
beste Land der Welt oder die Amerikaner sagen, USA sind das beste Land der Welt und so.
Wahrscheinlich die Mehrheit in der Mehrzahl der Staaten, wenn du fragst,
wo ist es besser oder wo ist es richtig, dann ja, da wo.
Ja, ein Mangel an Informationen herrscht da natürlich auch ein bisschen.
Ja, aber es ist aber auch das, woran man angepasst ist, das was man gewohnt ist.
Und damit kommt man klar, das funktioniert für einen selbst am ehesten noch,
als jetzt mit einer Verwaltung klarzukommen,
mit der man noch nie im Leben zu tun hat oder mit einem System. insofern, ja.
Aber es gibt natürlich Sachen, systemunabhängig, oder wo ich sagen würde,
das ist dann jetzt nicht unbedingt relativ, also wie zum Beispiel die ganze Müllthematik.
Ja.
Gut. Ich meine, ich habe das Gefühl,
wir müssen irgendwann nochmal, aber nicht so bald nochmal einen hinten dranhängen,
weil wir eine Reihe von Themen.
Ich würde mal folgendes vorschlagen. Wir machen jetzt vielleicht erstmal hier den Sack zu.
Das mal so als Reisebericht und erster Eindruck und dann schauen wir mal,
ob ihr Kommentare und Fragen zu dieser Sendung habt.
Dann kann man das ja vielleicht nochmal aufgreifen.
Aber ich würde sagen, als Reisebericht sollte es jetzt erstmal lang, oder Pavel?
Ja, ich denke, denke schon, wir haben,
Eine Menge Zeugs angesprochen, gab natürlich in sieben Wochen noch deutlich mehr.
Also wie gesagt, gerade das Politikthema hatten wir nur kurz angesprochen,
aber Militär hatten wir auch, Gesundheitssystem hatten wir auch.
Ja, vielleicht ist das auch genug insofern,
weil ja generell die mediale Berichterstattung über die USA,
die allgemeine auch sehr ausführlich ist.
Und ich gucken wollte, dass ich mich vielleicht hier auf ein paar Sachen auch
fokussiere oder ein paar Sachen, wo es einfach der Eindruck vor Ort ein anderer war,
als wenn man jetzt in Medien oder Filmen sich das Ganze anschaut.
Und ja, am Ende.
Die Leute leben irgendwie ihr Leben und versuchen das Beste draus zu machen
unter aber überwiegend jetzt lokalen Umständen und das Gefühl auch,
dass das Lokale wichtiger ist als jetzt das US-amerikanische,
weil das USA einfach so groß ist.
Und die USA und der Bund ist halt auch weit weg und distant und so und schwer
zu beeinflussen und zu verändern.
Und ja, deswegen, wie gesagt, die meisten Leute einfach leben in ihrem Umfeld und.
Um Job oder Karriere oder versuchen, ein Unternehmen aufzumachen.
Und das ist allerdings tatsächlich, ich sage mal, wenn es gelingt,
ein Unternehmen aufzusetzen, was irgendwie Traktion hat, dann lässt sich das
unglaublich schnell dort auch einfach entwickeln.
Also die Hürden und so sind in der Regel eher geringer Und es fühlt sich dynamischer an.
Also die ganze Wirtschaft, da ist man bereit, mehr zu opfern und auch,
was weiß ich, wenn es sein muss, Leute, Arbeitgeber ziehen dann auch 2000 Kilometer
weiter und verlassen ihre ganze Familie.
Das ist so das eine Extrem,
oder wir schon hatten, da wird dann einfach,
wenn die wirtschaftliche Grundlage nicht da ist, wird halt ein kompletter Ort
abgerissen oder untergegangen, lässt man einfach untergehen.
Und also da ist auch, was jetzt Unternehmen angeht, wird dort schneller gegründet
und schneller gewachsen und schneller pleite gegangen.
Ja, man reißt dann schnell was ein und das ist auch so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung,
weil derzeit befinden sich einfach die USA in einem sehr traurigen Zustand.
Aber ich habe auch so immer den Eindruck gehabt, wenn sie denn dann mal an den
Punkt gekommen sind, dass die Sache scheiße läuft,
dann können sie auch sehr schnell wieder in die andere Richtung marschieren,
während ich den Eindruck in Deutschland so überhaupt nicht habe.
Also hier weiß man es eigentlich die ganze Zeit, aber man ist überhaupt nicht
in der Lage, sich überhaupt in irgendeine Richtung zu bewegen und das ist manchmal auch nicht so geil.
Trotzdem wäre das jetzt nicht meine erste Wahl.
Ja, also hier hat es eher so eine Auffanggrenze nach unten,
die ist sozusagen das soziale Netz des Dichter geknüpft hier bei uns als in den USA.
Aber dafür ist es auch dann mühsamer und aufwendiger, sich zu entwickeln oder rasant zu wachsen.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt mal hier einen Punkt, Pavel.
Und warten mal unser Feedback ab. Also das war jetzt hier die kleine Bonusrunde,
die wir euch versprochen hatten.
Ich hoffe, es war was für euch dabei. und ja, ansonsten lesen wir uns und hören
bei uns, wenn wir uns dann hier wieder um die wichtigen Sachen des Lebens kümmern.
Okay, macht's gut.
Bis dann. Tschüss.